[Music]
[Music]
whoa kids you caught me spoke at one of
them completely legal cbd cigarettes
here on the internet as we prepare
to do our show welcome to fat man beyond
i'm the very handsy kevin smith
and my name is mark bernardin with just
a pointer
yay finger in mark bernardin they'd call
them
over if he worked at uh marvel back in
the day in the bullpen they'd be like
finger in mark bernard that wouldn't go
at all these days
back then you can get away with that
kind of thing like smiling stan
jolly jack finger and mark
handsy hank welcome kids
uh it's sunday night apologies for going
so late
uh some people have complained uh of
course the good folks over in
in the uk are like boy
because you know they'd like to watch
the show
at a decent time but we had to go a
little bit late uh this week or a lot
late
not because of me not because of
fingering mark bernardin
let's uh bring in uh [ __ ] bamfoy to
take his medicine hey
babe banff man get in here
what uh tell them what you were doing
why we couldn't start earlier
i was making a uh i was shooting
directing a video game
a series of video game commercials today
uh for a game called big cooking now
they just got way more than they
they bargained for you know what's the
name big
booking big cooking it's a game where
you're a chef in the kitchen
uh it's like an iphone game and you like
it's like uh you pay a
buck or two to play you play against
somebody else and whoever gets the most
points
wins like the pot so like you put in a
dollar and i put in a dollar we play
against each other
and then the the winner of the game gets
like a a buck 85 and then the company
keeps like 15 cents
sounds like gambling it does i don't
know if we're allowed to call it that
but uh
i knock it no no it's friendly waiting
for rocks man and so you were doing that
all day or yesterday or whatever yeah so
i did that yesterday morning
and uh all afternoon today and andrew
who
will be joining us again soon on the
show uh
is uh was my dp so a little
little fat man reunion he's been a dog's
age since we saw
andrew mann since we stopped going to
the actual scum
and villainy cantina but we'll be headed
there soon tell them when banff man
uh so we're coming back on tuesday
june 22nd uh all the restrictions are
lifting and we can have people back in
the bar
and then i think we're going to do
another show
that saturday as well so we're going to
do a
a double dose to uh
to bring in live shows again
wait so wait there's gonna be another
show there that's not me and mark
no well no we're gonna we're doing fat
man on tuesday the 22nd
the late night show the like show that
starts at
8 p.m and then on saturday we're going
to do a 2 p.m
show i believe is what we had discussed
so for all the people for all the people
who can't
stay up all night on tuesday to come see
us they can come see us saturday
afternoon
[ __ ] a sounds like a plan where will
they be able to get tickets when that
happens
uh seesmod.com and also
uh facebook.com scum and villainy
cantina
uh there it is kids come out and see me
and mark soon
uh as the world returns to normal
go back to doing exactly what we were
doing
going to that bar doing this in person
yes and then not doing it for a couple
of months
but those two then we'll go back to this
for a while
i'll be on the east coast mark will be
on the west coast but then
like september every damn week in the
bar
just like we used to um we of course uh
get to do this every week ladies and
gentlemen uh because
some folks clear a path for us man
uh they're called sponsors ladies and
gentlemen
they sponsor the show and this week we
got a couple sponsors the first up
is one of our favorite man and certainly
my wife's favorite because every time
they send a package
because we're about to do an ad the
package gets absconded but that's right
kids we're talking about
native man go to native.com
nativedeo.com
fatman right now while we're talking
about it or
go to nativedeo.com and use the promo
code fat man to check out
you're gonna get 20 off your first order
can you believe that man that's
nativedeo.com fat man or use promo code
fat man at checkout for 20 off your
first order kids
don't stink like we're so used to being
indoors now because the pandemic we're
used to living with our stink
those who know us are used to living
with our sting or about to re-enter the
real world
you can't come see us at the scum and
villainy cantina live
with stank you gotta smell good man you
know how you smell
good you just just cover yourself head
to toe
in native deodorant ladies and gentlemen
it's safe as a kitten
because they got any of that aluminium
in it that they send over from england
all the time that aluminium
none of that you know why because it's
almost vegan safe you can eat this if
you were on a desert island and all you
had were some native bars
number one you'd be smelling good number
two you'd probably be chowing down
you my friend are eating a meal because
all of those contents
are plant-based tell them mark i feel
like we should also say
don't eat the deodorant
you can i thought i was very clear about
the desert island situation market
very rarefied [ __ ] breathing there
but you know like native is on a mission
to overhaul your entire hygiene routine
by putting the care and self-care with
products
carefully made to work against odor that
are made with simple ingredients
and smell great you can get their
deodorant body wash and scents like
coconut and vanilla
coconut and pineapple citrus herbal musk
yeah you can lavender and rose and more
you can even build your own personalized
product bundles
mix and match through your favorite
scents and keep them on rotation so you
got something for every occasion
this product is legit wonderful kids and
uh
it works for me strong enough for a man
well we can't use that ad but like
i'm telling you right now looks like a
pump feels like a no no can't do it you
can't do that
um 30 minutes or it's free can't do that
either
uh my wife swears by this [ __ ] i
honestly feel like the only reason our
marriage is still going
is because i get the free native and she
takes it uh
my shower looks like what i assume the
owner of native
shower looks like all native products uh
stacked high
i wash my hair with native products i
wash my body
with native products i stick native
products under my armpits
when i go to sleep at night mark what do
you think i'm dreaming of
uh cheeseburgers and native
i'm a [ __ ] vegan i stopped drinking
about cheeseburgers three years ago it's
all native now
nothing but native uh the good folks at
native deodorant
uh have been proud sponsors of jane of
uh fat man beyond
the you know i've got a lot of shows fat
man beyond
for many years now ladies and gentlemen
please
go show them the love that my wife
shows them but pay for it that's the
difference between
my wife and everyone else she's like you
still got any of that
you got any of that free native d.o and
i'm like why don't you just buy it like
everybody
else first taste is free i tell her and
then she gets to go out and
get it herself but you know what she
does she goes to nativedeo.com ladies
and gentlemen
and then she uses the promo code
fat man and you know why because she's
going to get 20
off her first order stay fresh stay
clean with native by going to
nativedeo.com
fat man or use the promo code fat man to
check out and get 20
off your first order man that's
nativedeo.com
fat man or use the promo code fat man
check out for 20 off your first order we
thank
slobberingly grateful to the good folks
at native deodorant for sponsoring
tonight's episode the first half
of tonight's episode of fat man beyond
the second half ladies and gentlemen
um we got a whole different sponsor
because i don't know if you kids know
this or not but
uh it is the 40th anniversary weekend
of raiders of the lost ark 40 years ago
indiana jones entered our lives kids and
so the good folks at paramount
uh have put together the sweet ass
package where when we go into the q
a portion of the show uh and raiders of
the lost ark takes over as our sponsor
you're gonna get get a chance to win
this prize pack tell them what it is
mark
they're gonna get to win a fabulous new
4k ultra hd
box set collecting all four of the
original indiana jones movies
been remastered with hdr 10 and dolby
vision
state of the art told me at most for
optimum picture and sound quality
just in time to celebrate indiana
jones's 40th birthday
he's probably you know i mean yes
harrison ford has been getting double
arp emails for a long time but now
indiana jones himself is old enough
to think about retirement not that he
will but he could
we know he's not going to retire we saw
a photo of him on set this week wearing
his
wearing his mask being a good guy man
this cup of coffee
holding his coffee ready to ready to do
it he's like which one's this crystal
what i don't give a [ __ ]
he ready to go i'm telling you man james
mangle is gonna make a fantastic movie
but
until then we can uh bathe ourselves
in the stephen spielberg and george
lucas glory
of raiders of the lost ark indiana jones
in the temple of doom
yeah uh indiana jones in the last
crusade and indiana jones the last one
uh is that part of this kit as well uh
yeah you know you can't
you're never gonna be able to not get
the kingdom of the crystal skull
look i'll take it i want it i don't care
about the rest of the internet i'm a
completionist mark
so i'll take that crystal skull and i'll
put it right
i'll take it if they give it to me when
i buy the other three
um we'll later on we'll spend some time
talking about
uh the indiana jones movies particularly
raiders of the lost targets me and mark
both reminisce
about the day that we saw it because
kids
we saw it in theater well i could speak
for myself i saw it in a movie theater
day one what about you mark i don't
think it was day one but it was
definitely the original run
and that's saying something because that
was back in the day when movies would
like
be in theaters for a year then disappear
then come back for a triumphant re
another return engagement like you could
see it in theaters like e.t you could
see in theaters for a long time
star wars would go and come and go and
come but i saw it in the first run so i
feel good about that i saw
raiders of the lost ark 43 times
in the cinema as the europeans say thank
you
i uh those were the days where your
parents would drop you off at the
multiplex and you'd spend all day
hopping from movie
to movie and raiders played for so long
so
every time i went to see a movie for
like almost a year straight when that
movie was done i would just go watch
raiders the lost ark again
and it wasn't like you can just pop in
and look at a little bit and leave like
once you're in the theater you got to
bury so they don't see like hey man you
wouldn't pay for those tickets
so i watched the whole movie all the way
through all those times we'll talk about
that and so much more
in the second half of the show when we
go to q a and the best question of the
night ladies and gentlemen
is going to walk away with that
tremendous box set courtesy of
the good folks at uh who's responsible
for this
paramount's doing it paramount paramount
aaron still has like the home video
rights at the very least to those first
four movies
even though disney bought um lucasfilm
yeah that's what i thought i thought
this was part of the disney world
uh hey you know who would know about
this sort of [ __ ] banff man
yo banff man little lucasfilm [ __ ] get
in here he's so abused on his last
couple of outings
if anybody knows it's got to be you
what's going why
did they did disney buy raiders of all
star
i feel like they did well it's weird
because when disney bought
lucasfilm 20th century fox owned
a new hope so a new hope didn't like
carry over into the uh
on the distribution side of of
the pictures so like when they when they
first put those movies up before disney
bought fox
a new hope had the 20th century fox logo
and they stripped it off
empire and jedi because uh lucas
owned those and then all the prequels
just to himself
so i imagine this has got to be
something
similar to that like maybe disney
has the rights to the movies going
forward
but paramount still has the distribution
rights to the
initial four three
plus that other one uh indiana jones
movies
gavin haleck in the chat says
kevin is selling pirated dvds we're not
selling a pirated dvds are here are we
i don't believe so yeah i'm trying i'm
trying to work in this business i'm
gonna get thrown out for bootlegging for
heaven's sakes
trunk full of cds yes
as you'll find me out in the parking lot
of the the uh arby's across from the old
uh uh what's that place where they sell
a lot of
hip records and [ __ ] like that tower
records
the other place that other joint you
know goody
not urban not not the [ __ ] maul
suburban
amoeba i'm gonna be in the parking lot
of the [ __ ] it's not even
maybe it's a hardy's i don't know across
the way the joke fell apart i'm gonna
let it die right there
point man um yes we're not i
when disney bought all the marvel movies
like paramount held iron man for a
minute but then it eventually went to
disney i wonder if that will happen with
with the indiana jones movies um i mean
there will probably be some kind of
arrangement that those studios make so
that
you know disney can release the giant
five film box set
at some point just as i'm sure they made
some financial payment to paramount to
get iron man
you know lock stock and barrel but yeah
i mean it's
this kind of thing happens all the time
where these studios all are kind of
sharing
in a piece of ip you know i mean we
spiderman is still a sony
property but marvel's got its fingers in
it and they can
they can sort of negotiate and they can
absolutely make things happen that'll
that'll
benefit both sides you heard it right
here from finger and mark bernard
first he said they got their fingers in
it and stuff willie jackson on
the chat is going kevin you said that
you met harrison ford you never said
anything about directing his wife
because she was in supergirl first off
i've never met harrison ford second off
i didn't even direct his wife and
supergirl because i came on season two i
think she was only season one
but i've never met uh harrison ford i
don't think i've ever even
had like uh holy [ __ ] it's harrison ford
like uh you know of course
i've met and worked with mark hamill
back on jay and silent bob strike back
many other things since then but most
recently
mark worked with mark hamill in
a little project perhaps you might have
heard of this week
called masters of the universe
revelation
i've i it seems as if i've seen it in
passing
trending once or twice more on that
later
um but i've met of course and worked
with uh the late great carrie fisher
but i've never i i don't run in the same
circles as harrison ford which is crazy
because i hear he's a big stoner
so you'd imagine we'd work well together
but i
know jimmy mangold my mom been telling
me that since i was a little boy she'd
say tiger
you ain't no jimmy mangle cause i know
ma
i know you gotta rub it in man yeah
my mom would like to put it on french
you're many things tiger
and to me you're everything but you'll
never be jimmy mangled and i was like
fair enough he's gonna make a genius
movie dude i i don't know that guy
i got no skin in the game but i've seen
every movie he's made
and he's like he's the real deal he's he
he does it for the love i don't think
he's in it because he's like the money's
green i think he's a
a born storyteller so i think that i
think that indiana jones movie is going
to be amazing but
we'll talk more later on about raiders
of the lost ark
right now ladies and gentlemen we're
going to talk about uh what you came
here to see us talk about
um and that of course is
uh loki indeed marvel dropped another
show
uh this week it was on wednesday was
that right midweek it was
yeah it's it's they'd given us a little
break that we'd have the rapid fire one
two of one division and then falcon
winter soldier like you know what guys
take like a month off let's let's let
you get back to you let's let you pay
some bills
let's let you do some [ __ ] in the world
because you've been locked down waiting
for the next episode of these things all
the time let's give you some time off
and now they came back for us with some
loki
um now this uh series when they
announced it i was like i'll watch it
you know i i was like i'll watch it i
was like i'll do them a solid they need
the help i'll watch it it's marvel
they're always struggling i watch it i
was
like psyched for wandavision and
with uh falcon and the winter soldier
and
loki i was like yeah you know i'm sure
they'll be good and as we saw falcon and
the winter soldier was fantastic
episode one of loki
brilliant they're taking us on a
different journey all together we ain't
seen this show before
um spending this much time
with tom hiddleston in that character
role that made him famous and being able
to explore it and
then mark getting to the [ __ ]
feels of it all you know as he
sees the damage you know that he's
wrought across his life
and then sees like his life if he had
stayed in that timeline if they hadn't
if you hadn't
wound up in the tva so aside from like
some you know [ __ ] bureaucratic
laughs like watching a
show set at the [ __ ] you know dmv
you got that you've got uh you know
continuing
major character from like the earliest
marvel cinematic universe days with loki
taken from a center stage and then
you've also somehow in a story about
you know the god of mischief you got
this really
what's shaping up to be a kind of human
story
it smells like um you know
owen wilson has always been owen wilson
but
boy oh boy they they put him in
something that i'm like that's
i'll watch him do this every damn day
like he's it's the role he was born to
play
you know himself in in you know he's
because he's just such a charm
[ __ ] factory in this thing man like
uh like even with like when
loki's like i'm gonna burn this place to
the ground he's like you could start
with my office
or start with my desk like good [ __ ] man
funny [ __ ]
so i love what they've started with
um i was you know i thought they were
gonna give us two episodes to begin but
just one but no complaints no complaints
because it was a solid
almost an hour long [ __ ] episode and
quality
uh from top to bottom man i'm i'm in i
like this journey i like where we're
going
i'm not quite sure um you know as they
told spoilers that they told us at the
end they're gonna use him to hunt him
so i you know there's a whole bunch of
stuff we're about to find out
but i'm i'm on board man like you know i
know a lot of people are like marvel cut
you a check i [ __ ] wish
because really i cut marvel a check all
the time
they don't pay me for the privilege of
being like i like their [ __ ]
like i gotta pay for it like everybody
else and i we didn't even get [ __ ]
episodes early people got episodes early
i saw a lot of people in the press were
like
the first two episodes are great and i'm
like first two episodes
don't we know anybody but uh so no i
ain't no payroll i'm just a fan and
they're
they've not lost me yet um you know
they're uh they're they're they're
keeping my
that i'm i'm enthralled still enthralled
with what they're doing over there you
know i'm not like they're reinventing tv
they're just making movies as gigantic
you know [ __ ] tv shows like making tv
shows
as gigantic on ongoing features at this
point
um so i'm all for it i've read an
article somewhere where they're like
about
like 18 to 20 million per episode on
their shows which is
i think a lot of that is cast also a lot
of things like hey if we're going to get
hiddleston owen wilson and google about
the raw we got to pay them like this is
a movie
you know what i like about these shows
mark that just occurs to me the marvel
shows
on on disney plus is that when you get a
marvel movie
you know there's some good dialogue but
generally you're there for the big
action sequences and the [ __ ] fights
and stuff like that
so you know the dialogue
will take a back seat from time to time
now that they've got
hours to fill like you get
these long wonderful scenes where you
get a fantastic actor like tom middleton
and
and and owen wilson to sit there
in a [ __ ] room and talk to each other
like you know when i see scenes like
that i'm like oh maybe i could have made
a marvel something because all they're
doing is sitting down and talking to
each other
so you know in a world where it's like
they can't
every episode can't be a hundred million
dollars and stuff they
they you know take time to do scenes
where
nothing expensive is going on the most
expensive thing probably
in that one scene is the like you said
the two actors salaries
but like once you build that one set
like
just let them sit there and go for five
seven pages like
i i that's what i dig about marvel tv
shows they're they're letting us
hear more dialogue than we've ever heard
in those movies you get that feeling
um yeah i mean for for sure because once
once you have actors like that you want
to give them things to
to chew on right you want to give them
um
roles to to to dig into um
i i i'm i'm of a lot of different minds
about it
i'm of the mind of like um
one division was very much like we are
not gonna hand hold you whatsoever we
are like
[ __ ] it keep up or get off the train but
we're gonna drop you into three episodes
where you don't know what's going on
you're we're relying on the fact that
you're deep marvel fans
and so you're going to be doing a lot of
this work for us but we're going to kind
of leave you a bit of drift and that's
part of the thing we want to be
we want you to be disoriented and then
you get to loki
where it's like did you forget what loki
was about did you forget what happened
before
it's cool like half of this is a clip
show just gets you up to speed
on everything you need to know about
loki um and i just i found that
difference
of of sort of perspective and of
of technique kind of interesting on on
how
how they've traveled that spectrum from
you know
we're relying you to just hold on tight
to falcon winter soldier which is like
you know these guys
we're gonna see them in the middle of
action [ __ ] to this which is
did you forget who loki was so now we're
going to tell you exactly who loki is
um it felt a lot like a zero issue
to me um you know in comic books they
would do that like here's
here's the story before the story begins
proper you know
like let's just kind of let's spool it
back to you know
the first time that this person came to
the x-mansion
or let's show you like here's the week
before frank castle's family died
you know um because there's there's lots
of
of filling in blanks of you know here's
here's who loki is here's what he did in
the avengers here's what happened to him
in
in throw the dark world and ragnarok and
and here's what the tva
is and here's the sort of brazil 12
monkeys
kind of you know amazing design work but
here's the bureaucracy of time
and let's show you what that is like all
right that's kind of cool but like
the story doesn't really engage until
you're in the very
last moments of it when like there's a
there's an evil variant of you out there
that we need you to help us catch
like oh [ __ ] that's badass like there's
also the version of that
conversation that happens 20 minutes in
when it's like
we need you to help us catch you and who
better than you
to find out what you're gonna do next
like all right cool i'm here for that
um so like there's there's it's him
or do you think it's like lady loki um
i there's there's a little easter eggy
thing that
that i saw mentioned online when that
when you look at like loki's intake
papers for the tva
and they're like there's a little
running down of his like biographical
information whatever
and under sex it says fluid
and it's like oh which doesn't mean what
he prefers
it means it means his identity his
desire to identify
as a god can be anything he wants it to
be whatever will cause the most mischief
at any given time
and so if there's if he's lady loki
um if they are lady loki then
then that's that's a pretty decent a
it's a fun path to go and who do you
cast to be lady loki
and that's pretty amazing um but to even
just be able to play that stuff
for six eight ten episodes of a tv show
is kind of cool
like i like more where it's going than
what we actually got this episode
which is totally fine because it's like
it's hillston doing a thing we've seen
him do like five times
and he's always really good at it and
it's owen wilson doing that thing he's
done
since wedding crashes which we all like
very very much
but none of it feels um
but it's just fun to watch like yeah man
i'll watch this dude like
dig into his deep dark soul stuff and
and turn
loki from 2012 avengers into loki at the
back end of thor ragnarok which is a
dude who's been sort of humbled and
chastened
by time and experience and of course
he's going to watch that sequence where
thor says loki
i thought the world of you oh that's
that is one of my favorite scenes in
in all the marvel movies and i think
number one the sentiment is beautiful
but i thought hemsworth delivery was so
[ __ ] like
natural where he was just like okay i
thought the world of you
um and then side by side fighting side
by side and and loki just kind of
falling into
disappointment and [ __ ] yeah that was a
nice comedy it was
like my wife was not a she's not a you
know she didn't go deep in thor or
anything like that
so she was completely like oh he was in
the avengers
about like loki and um
you know i was like don't worry i'll
explain it as we go along
but they did a pretty good job of
catching you the [ __ ] up
like so even if you're unfamiliar with
those movies they literally are like hey
remember this scene
so you know she was i didn't have to
pause it it wasn't like wanda vision
which
which remember one division wasn't
supposed to be first what was going to
go first
falcon winter soldier was supposed to be
the first one out of the gate
that was a little more spoon-feedy or
just conventional it's like here are
these two guys you know who they are
it's it's lethal weapon
but with you know sam and and bucky um
so it didn't take a massive like
intellectual buy-in
to make sense of that but wanda with
vision was like oh [ __ ] you have to
you gotta you gotta be pot committed to
follow along with this especially until
they start revealing [ __ ] and like the
bottom of episode three top of four
right um and this is very much like
if you've never seen one of these before
if you've forgotten what loki was about
here's all the stuff and i never i mean
i i it's kind of ballsy i i don't know
if i ever would have thought that you
could have a pilot also be a clip show
um usually you wait until like season
four for a clip show
like first one on the gate here's a
bunch of footage you've seen before
i was like okay that's a way to do it
you know and i felt like
and and that's not to knock on it at all
because it's fun it's easy it goes down
very easy because it's [ __ ]
hiddleston he's having a blast
um but uh but yeah the the the amount of
hand-holding
they are now comfortable giving you um
as opposed to before
is it's interesting um which to be fair
again
it would have like we we wouldn't be
watching monovision now would we would
loki have come second
i don't think so i think it was always
they would they just flopped those two
you know because this is very much about
the multiverse like they're now teeing
up
like here's the [ __ ] that wander was up
to and why she's angry and where she is
and her whole emotional state
and then we're teeing up the idea of
multiverses and multiversal wars
and variants and madness there's even
part of that
like this sort of high up mr dna
sort of unmissed or tva animated thing
where they're talking about like
there's some variants if they crest too
high that way lies madness
and then multiversal wars and you saw at
some point like
crees fighting against the nova squadron
and [ __ ] like that it's like oh we are
just now
putting [ __ ] like that could be that
could be the next
infinity saga if you got to a multiverse
war
yeah i mean that's what where like
spider-man is fighting spider-man
like doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness is precisely where this is
all leading to
so it feels very much like like this is
kind of where we were supposed to be on
track
i'm liking it uh let's talk about two
things in the show
uh that were um
i i wouldn't go so far say controversial
but they definitely people were like
what the [ __ ]
uh number one the infinity stones
in the drawer what did you take that to
mean i mean they said over and over
again magic doesn't work here
right and in the comics like i saw a
piece i forget who did it maybe
comicbook.com or comic book resources
but
in the comics when they did the the
crossover
with uh marvel and dc
darkseid got the infinity gauntlet with
the stones but it didn't work
because it only works in the dimension
it's from so i saw a piece online where
they were going like
if that it holds in the in the movies as
well
then yeah outside of this timeline
those stones would do nothing but i
think the idea that they kept setting up
in the tva was like
magic doesn't work here so even if those
[ __ ] stones show up it don't
really matter but it seemed like they
had multiples of the stones am i right
yeah i mean i guess like multiple
timelines at some point
various variants had been sort of
captured
with one or two or three of the stones
and they just i got them in a [ __ ]
drawer and they don't do anything
and there's a great moment when like
loki looks at this
like sort of gallery of tin
jewelry and was like well [ __ ] i was
willing to mortgage an entire
universe for this stuff and here it is
just sitting in a drawer
powerless like you know that's that's
the stuff that i that i
totally did dig into which is reframing
for this
loki the futility of his entire plots
like what were you going to do when you
took over what were you already after
that's what i got out of it even with
the stones it's like when he was just
looking at him it's like oh my god like
i
my whole life i was trying to [ __ ]
get to that power
or help that guy get that power get
power so i can get power and [ __ ] and
ultimately
like this is it um but i somebody in the
time in the
comments was like the uh the stones are
magic perhaps i misspoke
aren't the stones are the stones not
magic
i mean they they they certainly do magic
i mean
i guess we could call them cosmic but
like
you know some of that [ __ ] was literally
magic
i mean i'm not fighting for it i got no
skin in the game but like
i since they literally said in the show
magic doesn't work here
and it it was in reference to the stones
i figured
yeah or it remembers both the stones and
to loki himself
um but i think that there's there is
because
dirt drop garage in the comments says
you guys are being way too fake about
loki show it sucked i i
legit [ __ ] like the show um did
people not like the show what was the
general consensus out there is it like
this guy
the general consensus is this is fun but
not a lot of it
you know like which is sort of where i
sit which is like you know this was a
good
time but uh but it's it's it's a zero
issue
it's like a one-half issue like it's not
the first issue of a comic book it's not
the pilot of a show per se
because very little happens it's it's
introducing you to the world but not the
real central conflict it's not engaging
you
in what that story is going to be um but
i think hiddleston is
gets you a lot of grace because he's so
[ __ ] fun to watch
um but you know dude in the chat
your opinion may vary you know it's
everybody's open to their interpretation
once we start once i asked about that
like it was flooded with i liked it i
loved it i liked it
so it seems generally it was positive
but that guy that hit me where i was
like oh my god maybe it didn't occur to
me
that somebody wouldn't like this my bar
is as we all know kids incredibly low
i'm a very easy man to please and if you
can ring my bell by making me cry
oh the world is yours but um this show
did not make me cry i didn't cry
during loki um and not because i'm like
it means it's not good enough they're
not trying i i don't you know other than
the real emotional moment with
freya like i don't think their whole aim
was to try to draw
tears at it as much as laughs and i did
laugh a couple times
um but yeah i like the show i'm not
being fake whatsoever
it's you'll never hear about something i
don't like i'll never trash something
because
that's a waste of time but if you don't
hear me talking about
something chances are you know i tried
it and didn't like it and [ __ ] so
when we do talk about a thing just
because we
like talking about things and we're
gonna continue talking about a thing i
mean we got how many more episodes loki
i don't even know uh mr banff
man might you know banff man
[Music]
i don't but i'll look it up
for that [ __ ] waste of time man
the banff has to be treated sacred so
the people
episodes according to the internet six
yeah
that's it that's it
the [ __ ] am i gonna do with the rest of
my life black widow
that's only two hours max
what's the next show after loki um
i think it's it's black widow then shang
chi and i think we get hawkeye
um they make us go to the movies for a
little while they're gonna make us go to
the movies
or sit at home thank you disney premiere
for 30 bucks you could sit here home and
watch black people they're going to keep
that up after the
after the pandemic's done you know so
far they show no signs of slipping
and if if the audience continues to go
to both places
in in robust numbers why would they
they could challenge me oh banff man is
back
we we do have what if coming out as well
excellent point well remembered now that
is where it bamf it in for
and it looks amazing hawkeye and
apparently at some point
uh she-hulk right oh that's right
shooting shulky right now i saw a photo
of mark uh ruffalo um
standing next to somebody i got it
looked like somebody posted one they
probably shouldn't have posted but
he had the suit on and the dots on his
face which you know indicates
that they're doing cg and [ __ ] like that
so yeah that's right we got that show to
look forward to and then uh mid
moon night moon night and miss marvel
which i thought
a couple weeks back we talked about the
i believe ms marvel's in the can already
so that's probably one of the
after hawkeye i imagine or before that's
right around hawkeye
all right so we got more seriously and
then there's chicken invasion
then there's armor wars then there's a
bunch of stuff in the
on the pipeline let me tell you
something man i've been at the
epicenter of a lot of affection this
week mark
because of the the masters of the
universe revelation
teaser trailer that came out and i'm
sure you felt it as well
and you know it's i'm sure i'm not
telling anybody
anything new uh when i say that uh this
is rarefied breathing for me i'm used to
making [ __ ] like walrus movies where
most people like go [ __ ] yourself
here i am involved in something that
like a lot of people love
and seem to love what we're doing with
it based on the teaser that they've
watched and stuff like that
and and i the compliment i've been
getting
over and over and over again from utter
strangers is
thank you for giving me my childhood
back
this looks like my childhood and stuff
like that
that is how i feel when you talk about
the marvel
movies and tv shows like when you when
you said secret invasion and armor wars
ins like my [ __ ] nipples got hard i
was just like
oh suddenly everything is right with the
world like that's right
we have [ __ ] amazing things to look
forward to
and you know they just they keep hitting
my sweet spot like i'll tell you when
they [ __ ] miss man
like you know i'm i'm hoping to god it
ain't eternals because eternals is the
one marvel property i'm walking into
where i know
almost nothing never read the books was
never i
can't say like i wasn't a fan because i
wasn't even aware of the [ __ ] books
man like they weren't rocking eternals
that hardcore when i was collecting
so i i'm i'm going in completely clean
i'm gonna need somebody sitting next to
me like walt flan again to be like oh i
pause this is what this means and this
is what this comes from and stuff like
that
but you know i'm still there it's not
like this looks like it sucks it's just
the one that i'm walking into and i've
got no childhood connection to so it's
gonna be an interesting test
to see if my love for the marvel stuff
is more predicated on my
you know nostalgia my childhood
affection or on the actual
current entertainments themselves
we'll see but i i like when you said
armor wars i was like
i got so happy i was like oh my god
that's that's right that's how those
masters of the universe fans feel when
they see that teaser and they're like oh
my god
it's just right um like i it's much like
you
there's some of these marvel things that
i'm not as connected to as others like i
was not connected at all
to guardians of the galaxy there was
another one you're right i wasn't
connected to that at all either i wasn't
that connected to ant-man like i knew
who he was
but like it was not a you know top 20
hero in my book but yeah
[ __ ] it i'll watch this this movie i i i
was not i too wasn't like [ __ ]
but i was just like i can't believe
we're in this world where they're doing
ant-man so i was more
i was more anticipatory of that than i
was of guardians you're right
eternals and guardians are now kind of
roughly this is that's why i think i
give eternals the benefit of the doubt
because i'm like i remember being like
the guardians the galaxy
what are they [ __ ] nuts and then you
know obviously they weren't nuts so
yeah it could work out yeah what would
you say no i interrupted you i'm sorry
no i mean there's none of these
automatically for me are like
not gonna watch it don't care um there
are some of them that i'm
a little bit more like okay like show me
something
and there's other ones that i'm just all
the way leaning in and be like [ __ ] yeah
like bring it to me right now want it in
my face
you know and i think right now loki is
is a little bit
i'm not gonna say wait and see because
i'm going to see every episode every
week
but just it's it's got a little bit
further to go
to engage me in what it is because i'm
still not entirely sure what it is yet
the world seems interesting
i i love the idea of the tva and i love
the idea of somebody like loki
kind of colliding with what that is that
seems like a dude
who does not truck well with systems and
bureaucracy
and so it would be mired in some giant
one looks like it's going to be fun
um and then there is that old saying
that any technology that is sufficiently
advanced will look like magic
and so perhaps that is how the the magic
of the infinity stones gets explained
which is technology we don't understand
yet
um in chat uh this one made me smile
daniel russell
and i don't think he had said it to
bigby smile well it says neutered he-man
thanks manscaped uh because the
commercials for manscaped all the time
um neutered he-man kids uh he new man
he man is no more nerdy in our show than
he was ever neutered in any
episode of masked he-man and the masters
of the universe
um i i don't understand why like
did everyone watch the show well
everyone uh largely
99 of the reaction to this teaser
um has been insanely positive there's a
very small percentage of people though
who are like
we're being [ __ ] bait and switched
they really feel like we went out of our
way to trick them
mark which is like fascinating to me but
in any event
that that makes me like smile because
apparently our advertising is effective
like this cat remembers
that we do manscape commercials and they
were not this week's sponsor
they weren't i would be more impressed
if the the gag was
he manscaped yeah i can't believe why
more people aren't hitting me with like
uh she man or something like that
because everyone keeps going like it's
woke
as i said on the internet this this our
series is
exactly as woke as as he-man in the
masters universe in the 80s
we literally do the same things they do
i'm spoilers kids
in the old show he-man would sometimes
get into trouble and his friends would
save him
i know because i literally watched every
episode
so i spoilers again
we do that in our show as well like
like there are moments when friendship
is is
the only way to get through something
and that's what we learned
watching every episode of he-man in the
massive universe
when we sat down to do our writer's room
so if that bub
if you're bumping into that you you
might bump into the old version of the
show
um but it i'm telling you i've never
felt
so much [ __ ] love dude like
for like people are so
like warm and [ __ ] wonderful
about the teaser um i
this is the crazy part ready so like
online it's easy for people to be like
you rock and
just as easy as is for them to be like
you suck this time around it was more
the former
way more the former like very minimal
ladder
nobody going you suck some people
suspect though
so i'm like the bait and switch
i've seen that a lot that's kind of nuts
but um
the the like overwhelmingly
positive response makes me so happy
because like
that teaser like while wonderful
you know and thank god teddy be sully
who's been our
you know shepherd to the entire project
like the the guy
who for whom we're making the whole show
he's the one that brought us into
netflix uh there are there's other
he-man or masters of universe projects
going on there's a
another show called he-man and the
masters of the universe and it's more
like uh i'm not it's wrong to say it's
kid show cause ours is a kid's show as
well
but definitely more youth-oriented with
cg characters and stuff like that
what is it i think it's like for new
fans like if you're a nine-year-old kid
and you've never seen it before
that's your on-ramp that's exactly it
and uh kind of a reinvention of the
franchise as well
and then of course they're always trying
to make the feature film which like i
i wish i had any sort of news for you
that's a completely different division
so
i only know what folks know online i
read the same [ __ ] you do i got no other
inside information on that but
we were hired literally to make the show
for like teddy and his age group who
grew up watching the show
for whom it was religion that's why like
i knew we would never fail with the show
because the guy who's in charge of us
the guy who signs our paychecks the guy
who made all of this happen
is the guy who knows more about masters
of the universe
than anyone watching this will ever
[ __ ] know
like and i'm that's not even an
overstatement that the dude is a
walking encyclopedia of motu and right
now if you're excited for
masters of the universe revelation you
are literally living in teddy b
celly's dream this is something he's
dreamed about since he was a kid
like when i first when i met with him to
get the job he was the one that was like
just do me a favor
when i was a kid i thought this was real
i thought every episode skeletor was
gonna kill he-man i was scared for him
he's like then i got older and i
realized that was never gonna happen
he's gone all i want is to feel that way
again i just want to feel stakes
i want to be i want to be convinced that
like something bad could happen to these
characters and stuff
he's going and just please don't treat
it silly
he's like you know it it's it's
low-hanging fruit for some people and so
they'll want to make fun of it they'll
want to like tease it make
pop culture references and stuff like
that you know i really thought he was
talking directly at me i'm like well
that's isn't that why i'm here
but he was like just do me a favor like
treat it
seriously just for once i just want to
see if this would work
this is his words and it shaped the
whole [ __ ] project
he goes treat it like shakespeare and so
i was like all right
like [ __ ] let's look we'll play this
serious as a heart attack and why not
it's not to say there's not fun in it
and levity and stuff
just like the show that we are
spiritually sequalizing
but it is there are stakes and we do
play it very seriously and so
teddy who's like guided us every step of
the way
he was the guy i asked this week because
the internet like
like blew up about the song choice for
the
piece of joke not not only were they
like nuts about like oh my god this
looks great
visually speaking that belongs to pat
and adam our directors at powerhouse
animation they're
absolutely [ __ ] brilliant man all
that big action
all that glorious animation comes from
those cats and the good folks of
powerhouse animation
so the um uh [ __ ] what was i just saying
now i lost my place
uh song banff trailer music
thank you so um i asked the good folks
in marketing
joey and the folks at marketing and
netflix i said
the internet like thinks that i picked
that song and you know me i don't like
to take credit for [ __ ] that i didn't do
so please tell me who picked that song
like what marketing person like said oh
let's take that song
and uh they were like uh a little birdie
told me it was teddy and i was like what
the [ __ ] are you serious they're like
absolutely and this is the charming
[ __ ] story
of why that song is in why
hero um i need a hero a whole alpha hero
by bonnie tyler is in our
teaser trailer ready for this so [ __ ]
sweet
and please internet like in a world
where you're like smith said this
write this [ __ ] story because it's
adorable
so teddy tells the marketing folks
like they give him a uh trailers with a
few like
song options and naturally we wanted an
80s song
so teddy writes back when i was a kid
i would put on the footloose soundtrack
and i would play with my figures
and choreograph fights to that song to
hero
so can we try a version with that
and they did and it [ __ ] on all the
downbeats the actions hitting and [ __ ]
like that's wonderfully edited
but that that came from the head and
heart of the guy who's been guiding this
project
from day one so you know
he's the greatest thing that that
happened to me i wouldn't have this job
were it not for him for rob david they
were like all right come on in
and you know it it i was safe the whole
time because
you could never go off the rails because
on one side you had rob who had written
the dc comics version of he-man the
master universe for the last few years
and on the other side we had teddy who
it's like if you
whenever you do a zoom with him his
background is literally all the motu
figures out of boxes
and they're the original ones from his
childhood so
like to give credit where credit's due
ted biaselle was the one that was like
let's put that song in there and and i'm
telling you as much as people were like
i've read all the feedback as much as
people were like oh my god it looks
crazy it looks like my childhood
the very next comment if if not the main
comment was like
that song slapped like what a great
[ __ ] choice you're brilliant and i
got a lot of credit for it but like
you know i said yes but that i was not
the guy ted
ted came up with that idea um that's
amazing
that's amazing yes there's it has been a
uh
a wonderful week in in eternia
um the love i think was was flying fast
and loose on the internet
for anything and anyone related to
masters universe
and i feel as if i'm probably getting
more love than i deserve
i think there's there's lots of people
who were like massive heroes revelation
from kevin smith and mark bernard and
it's like oh
so slow down team i think this is this
is from kevin smith
and i did some work on it like i i'm
doing the job of a
of a writer in the room on staff of a tv
show
i'm helping execute the showrunner's
vision um and it's not my vision
at all it is kevin's vision and so like
my job is
hey man this would be a fun idea and
kevin says you know what i like that hey
man this would be fun and he'd say i'm
not vibing on that and then i write a
script and i do some revisions
and then off it goes to the masters had
the masters at powerhouse who make it
look
awesome but um i i i
deserve and require about 40 to 50
less credit for how awesome this show
will be because
it is all it is all kev it is all you um
i said you're very sweet everyone uh
plays their part and does their role but
as anybody who watches the show every
week knows
you know there's a real good story man
right there who i'm always like oh my
god we should do that oh my god
stop sharing that you should do that as
a movie and stuff so
i you know it wasn't like uh well
let's bring mark along because like he's
a good guy like i've been sitting next
to a [ __ ] hardcore story man for
years time doing the show
so the moment i had a show where i could
give jobs and [ __ ] i was like thank you
pardon agreement um yeah i feel a little
bit bad
because um the trailer for the new
guardians of the galaxy video game
dropped today i think part of like an e3
uh
xbox whatever whatever and they also
used
i need a hero by bonnie tyler and it's
like
you know what i'm so glad we dropped
like four days ago
because you don't want to be the second
people to try and dominate the world
with that song on your fun ass trailer
i don't know if there's any truth to
this whatsoever but i heard a rumor and
believe me i have no connections to
you know disney plus or the marvel world
whatsoever but i hear that that song
plays in
in uh an upcoming episode of a tv show
that we're very excited about
with as well it's funny honey tyler's in
the air
i mean look let's be honest it probably
all stemmed from
when they did the luke skywalker episode
of
mandalorian they did somebody did a cut
of him coming in they did different
versions like here's the old
the star wars theme here's the the
[ __ ] music from you know the
[ __ ] duel the fates or whatever [ __ ]
and then they did a version with bonnie
tyler's
hero so you know it's
i think it was in the ethos and [ __ ]
in the ether
not ethos in the ether and i think a
bunch of people smart marketing people
were like
thank you uh but you know great song is
a great [ __ ] song like there's a
reason that song has lasted for 40
[ __ ] years and stuff
totally but you know it's it's good to
be first out of the gate
if you're going to be you know in the
same pen
with another thoroughbred who wants to
use the same song so bully for netflix
and geeked week and for choosing for
whatever reason they did
that this was the time to debut that so
well done everybody
it was uh insanely insanely well done
and
i can't wait for people to to see the
rest of if you like that teaser at all
wait until you see the story trailer
this has been a very difficult
uh show to to talk about without
spoiling things uh mark which allows for
a lot of interpretation
in the world and stuff like that but
like
the story i i've you know we the teaser
trailer just dropped i have seen
the story trailer which will come
closer to the actual release of the show
and once you see the story trailer kids
everything will make absolute sense
anyone going like i heard it that you're
gonna go
oh i see i'm not gonna say i can't say
that like and everyone will
[ __ ] love it because you know some
people would
you know are dug in and feel what they
feel but
there's like i i love the story trailer
because there's a line in the trailer
that comes straight out of the show
that like literally puts it all on front
street where you go
oh there it is yes um
you know there's so it's been
like you know it's it's been tough for
me because i'm i mean
always incredibly [ __ ] forthright and
honest and stuff
but like there's like i can only go so
far and i can't
say some things that would like dispel
like a lot of chatter because i'm not
allowed
like like literally not allowed to spoil
the [ __ ] thing i don't want to lose
this job i like this [ __ ] job
so you know it's when you work for
somebody else when they're my toys like
if i'm making clerks three
you'll hear all about it kids i'll tell
you every [ __ ] detail so much so that
you can skip the movie
most people do when it comes to my stuff
but since
i'm working for somebody else both
mattel and netflix i i'm not as free
to divulge all the details of the things
that i'm working on and stuff
um so i can't say you know one or two
things that would just kind of
wave away you know a lot of like people
going like why here it is this
um but like uh you know me i'm i'm not a
i'm a lover not a fighter mark
and i always like to make people happy
um
i saw like a story this week like
um where i was like oh like my
my instincts to want to make people
happy come to the forefront but like i'm
not gonna be able
to do it so online like there were a
bunch of people that were like you
better apologize to
clownfish because there was a gentleman
named clownfish or website clownfish
where
they s they had put up a tweet a lot
like a
last year maybe a march i don't know but
this is the tweet
and i responded to it
in the tweet i it said uh uh bounding
into comics had this because i
couldn't find the tweet has been deleted
it looked like i couldn't find it but
they wrote what was in the tweet so it
it they said here on bounding into
comics
uh in march clownfishtv shared a rumor
from an alleged insider
that detailed quote and this was a quote
tila in our series tila is a better
he-man than adam
and he steps aside to let her
and her girlfriend take over hero
duties okay now that was tweeted
and so this is what i tweeted back ready
and this is march 2020. i said as
showman i was trying to be nice i was
like
and fun like you know keep it light as
show runner i really could have used
these story suggestions before
we lock the scripts however no he-man
does no stepping side and tila has no
girlfriend
in our show she has a friend who's a
girl but she has no
girlfriend um that would be like saying
he-man has a boyfriend he has a friend
who's a boy in the show he doesn't have
a
boyfriend um the story line is pretty
dark and way metal
before revelation we were calling it end
of the universe
so you know i didn't think that was very
confrontational but like
to literally respond to the this person
said
this is what i'm told the show is about
i'm going to read it again
tila is a better he-man than adam and he
steps aside to let her and her
girlfriend take over
hero duties i that is
i i wish i could apologize to clownfish
just because like i like peace i like
you know
i'm a lover not fighter mark but like
that is
patently untrue there's not a single
part of that mark you've read the
scripts
i have i'm gonna close my eyes and not
make any eye contact with mark
mark how am i right to say that that was
absolutely untrue
um that that what was tweeted and
alleged is a falsehood
now i'm not saying like somebody's
[ __ ] lying i'm not the one accusing
anybody of the line i'm just saying
that was tweeted and i tweeted that's
not true because
that description is patently
unfucking true untrue so
uh there was another tweet at one point
where i guess
um they had uh like
retweeted somebody screen rant
was retweeted i think by clownfish or
something this goes to
may 28th and their tweet's unavailable
but i in it they put up like in the
synopsis it says this
so i had tweeted with all due respect to
screen rant i've read every master's
official script for our shows plus wrote
a few
and viewed four amazing animatics while
tila is as present as she's always been
in masters universe adventures
and she plays a big role our series
is literally all about
he-man mark as somebody who's worked on
the show and read the scripts
i'm gonna close my eyes would you agree
with that statement
yes the show is all about he-man
so mark i you know me i'm not a fighter
do i have something to apologize for uh
i don't believe so
stated that's not me picking a fight man
all
love to to clownfish or anybody who's
like you know
uh
saying that like you know this ain't
that this show is a bait and switch but
like
i'm responding to something that was
written
and i i swear to you what was written is
patently untrue doesn't resemble our
show one iota
so i don't know what i could say five
years of american discourse have proved
anything
it's that presenting some people with
facts
that might dispel closely held but
entirely fallacious beliefs um
can seem an affront when none was
intended
a corrective is not an assault that was
not an assault there was one
somebody said yeah but one other time
you got saucy with him so okay i'll read
you this one other tweet and you tell me
if this was saucy
i said uh
in i put up that tweet as show blah blah
blah and then i
commented about on the same tweet and i
said also clownfish instead of
posting your foe insider info because he
said that it was from an insider
so i'm quoting insider i'm not i'm not
saying like
you know i'm not being facetious i was
using his line
i said here's a real story mattel made a
behind the scenes video featuring our
actors recording
so a fan took some of mark and lena's
dialogue and spliced them into old
filmation clips and i gave him a clip
uh so i you know ever trying to keep it
light
i'm not like i ain't here to fight i
love this [ __ ] like i don't find any
thing in pop culture worth fighting
about ever like if you don't like it
that's [ __ ] great i'm sorry but like
if i like a thing i like a thing um and
you know when i see misinformation
like i correct it that that tweet going
back to march was
absolute misinformation and you know
some people like well i've seen the
synopsis for the show i'm like
great does it does it sound like that
tweet
because that's not the show i don't i
don't know how but you know what don't
matter
when the story trailer goes out there
then people will be like
oh that
banff oh look is here how are you banff
man
good i'm just looking at some of the
chat and a lot of people are saying like
well the people from clownfish
are the real he-man fans and the og
he-man fans so
i'm just gonna say i'm 40 years old
he-man was the thing when i was a kid
that i
cosplayed that i like went out and i got
the stupid
like cheap two-dollar dime store plastic
sword and i have the power
in my backyard my brother and i played
he-man
um it just that's what all the photos of
i'm not
playing han solo or luke skywalker i'm
playing he-man
so i would consider myself one of the
target audience og fans of
he-man and i i may have slipped into
your house and seen
a handful of these episodes and it
i i'm also a fan of the 2002 he-man
reboot series so i've i've watched all
the he-mans
um and i've loved all the he-mans
and i love your he-man and i think it's
it's probably the best
he-man i've seen especially as
an og fan at the age i'm at now
meaning if i go back and i watch the
original 163 episodes of he-man
my memories of those shows
are different than what those shows are
like i as a kid those were the most
epic those were avengers end game
but for me watching your show
it was the way i remembered the show as
a kid
so the way that the og he-man plays for
a five-year-old
kid the new series plays for like a 40
year old
kid i'm i'm with you on that man like
i'm
i'm not i'm not a genius kids uh and
never claimed to be
uh unless we're talking about making
convenience to our movies in which case
i do have some
area of expertise over a lot of others
um
but i've watched a lot of tv i've
watched a lot of movies over the years
and even though i've never done
something
like this like you know taking on
fantasy characters this large um
i you know i like i i
i come from the same place that
that most of the audience comes from
where it's just like
you know i dig marvel because they
reserve my
my childhood to me in compelling new
ways
like marvel was our lodestar in the
writers room
like the idea of you're not gonna
have anybody come in sit down and be
like they [ __ ] it up
can't do it i mean again i don't know
how many different ways i could say this
like i'm not even being facetious this
isn't like hollywood
[ __ ] i literally would have been
fired
by the man who hired me because the man
who hired me
loves he-man way more than anyone on the
internet
like wait the dude has reorganized
all the functioning principles of his
life and work
to get to the position where he could
[ __ ] demand that they make
this he-man series like that dude would
have [ __ ] fired me i promise you
like you know i know some people like
come on you're kevin smith
yeah that means i don't get hired a lot
so
unless you do a thing correctly ouch you
[ __ ] go and it's not like i'm a
netflix golden boy or some [ __ ] so
trust me like if we had [ __ ] stepped
off the path or if this show
was not masters of the universe like i
i i'm not i'm not [ __ ] kidding i
would have been let go
of like and when it comes to the like
the clown fish of it all
second it's like it is not a matter of
the depth of your fandom you know or
your relative depth of fandom compared
to anybody else out there
it's a matter of i know what's true and
what isn't true
because i have knowledge that somebody
else doesn't have
that does not require you to have to
pass some fandom test
to be able to prove the veracity of a
statement like
i will i believe but but at the same
time i'll happily take a fandom test
especially when it comes to motu
absolutely
yeah i mean right like you know if you
would ask me
two years ago when i started the project
i still would have been like yeah i'll
take that test but i would have been
like well you know
i got a 50 50 chance of of winning now
holy [ __ ] like i'm so steeped in the
motu
the mattel mini comics lore every
episode of [ __ ] the filmation show
um we watched the 2002 show as well we
didn't go as
deep but like it was wonderfully done
and very close in spirit to what we've
done and as much as they continued
the story you know is all the characters
they all look like the way they're
supposed to and the way you know them
and stuff like that
so you know i it's i'm i'm happy to
to to i'm you know i'm not looking for a
fight but like if anybody's like you
don't know [ __ ] he-man i'm like all
right well
i guess you're you're about to see like
you know in a month
yeah it's like i don't know particle
physics but i know e equals m c
squared here so like if i can if you
have e equals m c mc1
i'd be like i have the no that's wrong
because this is right and i have the i
have the homework to prove it
like you just knew a thing he didn't
know and he got defensive about what he
didn't know
i'll never forget finding out that chris
nolan like didn't grow up steeped in
batman
like you know you watch the [ __ ] dark
knight return or the dark knight or even
batman begins and you're like oh my god
this is [ __ ] who knows he goes
deep and hard on batman and stuff
but you know he he grew to know batman
incredibly well but it's not like he was
like oh this [ __ ] was in my dna and
whatnot
like so i'm not believe me i ain't
comparing us to chris nolan by
stretching the imagination i'm just
echoing what mark was saying
as much as like sometimes like the
world's biggest fan of a thing
is is not like the person
who gets to create it sometimes they get
somebody who's just like
strong at storytelling yeah and i
brought together a team that was very
strong at storytelling
and got lucky in as much as i pitched a
story which again i don't know how many
different ways i could say this the
original story was called
masters of the universe colon the end of
the universe so it's pretty
pretty [ __ ] bleak tale you know
pretty you know in terms of where teddy
was just like i want steaks i'm like
well
it don't get stickier than this
so i i like angus or we can we could do
the end of the universe
i i look forward to everyone else seeing
i really now i'm so
thank you for everyone who said kind
things about the the teaser and like you
know
my god the amount of coverage we got
like the netflix people
were ecstatic all the folks in marketing
teddy was over the [ __ ] moon
we trended like in the top five again um
the uh you know at one point orco was
trending and skeletor
like i you know i i've been listening to
mark
be skeletor for over a year at this
point but this was the first chance that
a lot of the world got to hear
marcus skeletor and that captured a lot
of people's imaginations so they wrote
about that
um but yeah we're getting close and uh i
can't wait for people to see it but the
t
the teaser trailers out there right now
if you haven't seen it the story trailer
will come closer to release and then
july 23rd kids
you get to go to eternia um with with me
mark
and all the and dia and and tim and eric
and teddy and rob and and all the cast
and the powerhouse animation kids pat
and adam again i can't sing these
[ __ ] praises enough
pat and adam are directors man like you
know when you watch like
uh in the big fight sequences in the
teaser like with the giant [ __ ]
fist and [ __ ] like that that that's the
boys
boys are just [ __ ] good like the boys
were always like
you know look this dialogue is great
but like we know cartoons and people are
coming to see
like the action so we started early on
building in big action set pieces
per each episode and then when we saw
what the boys could do
we started leaving more space to be like
all right let's put [ __ ] two
action sequences in here and stuff so
you know
watching the the teaser watch people
react to the teaser all week
has made me re-watch the show twice
where i was like oh my god like they
picked up on that i'm gonna go back and
start watching that again
and then just rewatched it all the way
through um i can't wait for
people to see it uh and uh i guess
that's coming soon uh we're going to
have a
i'm not going to be here in california
when the show comes out i'll be back
east in jersey for the summer
so at jane solinbob secret stash on
uh july 23rd when the episodes drop
we're gonna have a revelation
celebration
and uh give out some motu toys to kids
under 10
and sign posters and [ __ ] like that so
if you've seen the show and you're like
you [ __ ] suck you come down and tell
me right to my face and [ __ ]
and i'll [ __ ] be like can you hold on
and i'll call teddy and be like
someone would like to speak to you and
you could talk to the boy whose dream
we're living in man
um so yeah it's uh don't forget there's
a dark horse
comic book tied in there's a story that
me and rob came up with and tim one of
our writers
wrote the issues that's kind of a
prequel
to uh to our our series
so it ties in like pretty damn well um
and tim
like i can't like i'm always like about
to spoil [ __ ]
let me tell you right now i did press
last week
where like i like i
you know everyone's in the i'm i'm in up
in the future
because we're in like the the next part
of the show like first part of the show
has been done for a while
so we're like i've just heard bears
score for
episodes seven and eight and it's
[ __ ] sublime
like i don't know how this this guy
[ __ ] out does himself every episode
but oh my god he wrote a piece of music
for evil in an episode [ __ ] seven and
eight that is
it's sublime it could be in [ __ ] star
wars man like so
so i'm up in the future and we were
doing press and somebody asked me a
question
and it was about the first five but i
responded
with an answer from the back five
yeah yeah and the person looked at me
like i remember that and i was like
oh like you know i used to i used to
read yeah
you didn't see a thing i used to read
those stories about like whenever tom
holland spoiled something i was like
why can't this kid just keep his mouth
shut now i understand
like sometimes you're like so like by
the time
you're having conversations with people
about promotional stuff or whatnot
you've lived this [ __ ] like it's it
happened a long time ago
so yeah there was an add to it i'm a
stoner as well
so yeah there was a moment or two where
i was like yeah well when that happens
no wait you know and then people were
like ah oh
straight yeah exactly i'm glad it
happened now because it's it's
early and it was too early for a lot of
people to pick up on and stuff
but you know if it had happened after
the show dropped then people would be
like i think i know what just happened
here
i think you spoiled something from the
[ __ ] next
part and [ __ ] um yeah it's been a blast
man
i that was probably one of my favorite
days in my career was
sitting here all day long watching
people's reaction to that teaser going
oh my god it's
like it is it's it's happening it's
working like it's
it's everything we hoped we hoped that
people would be like this looks exactly
much
and people literally [ __ ] wrote that
you know we
like there's a saying that i borrowed
from a friend of mine i
stole i don't borrow adam siegel who is
an exec on
uh a movie i made years ago called the
couple of dicks
which was released as a picture called
cop-out um
but it's a working title the original
title the script was a couple of dicks
adam siegel who works with mark platt uh
mark platt the mega producer adam
once was talking about eating mcdonald's
french fries
and he used this expression that i've
like i said oh my god that's beautiful
and i've stolen it and i've
used it everywhere he goes oh that just
tastes like a happy childhood
and that's what that teaser trailer
tastes like a happy childhood man that's
what we're
hoping the whole [ __ ] show tastes
like a happy childhood so
that little taste that went out there
you know on on thursday
and got everyone so excited if you if
that tastes good
oh [ __ ] wait until you see what's coming
all right enough about masters of the
universe for heaven's sakes
um but thank you thank you for all and
again
clownfish no no this is in a fight i
would love to apologize it's just
i can't say i'm sorry for something that
was inaccurate
it's still inaccurate um
i think you'll i think i think you'll be
happy i'm telling you right now even the
people that are like
i think it's a bait and switch when they
see it they're going to be like oh
you know i'm not going to say that
they're all going to come back and be
like we're so sorry i'm not looking for
that but i
i think i don't think well i don't think
we have to wait till then i think once
they see the story trailer everyone will
be like
and now now i see
but until then for a clownfish he's not
very funny
you know he's a fan like everybody
everybody's a fan
you know and so people get passionate
sometimes you know
passion goes and is misconstrued and
but we're all on the same page like look
i want to make the same [ __ ] show
that they all want to see
and i believe we did so we'll you know
we'll see in a month change um all right
enough about all our personal [ __ ] we've
been talking about all [ __ ] we want to
talk about
we know everyone's here for the [ __ ]
news man we're an hour and a half into
this [ __ ] adventure
and it's time to talk about the news and
there's one man who goes out and he
puts his nose in the dirt he digs up the
dirt ladies and gentlemen he makes the
news happen
give it up for mr detective mark bernard
finger and mark bernardin as they call
him in the news business
marked with the news what do we got
what's going on this week i hear there's
a masters at the universe show coming
mr detective mark bernard here with some
news um
we're going to lead we're going to lead
with a couple of rumors the this this
seems like some of the
the chatter that got people the the
chatter that matters
was about things that may or may not be
true the first of which
is that uh namor has been cast
as the villain of black panther wakanda
forever
uh according to the folks at illuminy
um absolutely neymar is the bad guy
and uh narcos mexico star tenoch
huerta has joined the cast as an unknown
villain and after some intense digging
the illuminati has learned
euler minority has learned uh from their
sources that
tenac huerta will be playing another
none other than neymar the submariner
now um i 100 believe that neymar is the
bad guy
um it does make some sense they they
teed it up in end game
you know relatively well with their
there's a there's an underwater
earthquake we're going to follow that up
what happens off
the african plate we'll get to that in
three years
yeah um what i what i don't believe is
that the
the role has been cast um or the very
least that has been cast by this
particular guy
and that is only because um nobody else
has picked up this story
um nobody else um nobody else like
variety or entertainment weekly with
hollywood porter or date or deadline
all these sites that absolutely would
traffic in this and would love the
love to get the clicks that go along
with the casting of the the prince and
neymar
have followed up with any anything
resembling a confirmation
so i'm not entirely sure that that is a
it has some veracity to it
that said they're going to be in
production relatively soon
um there's a script in hand they've got
a release date um it's coming out
you know in almost a year july 8th 2022
is when the release date's supposed to
be so like
they're probably if not in production
about to be relatively soon
um but yeah i just that that it seems a
little early
and the sourcing doesn't seem that
strong happy to be wrong
but i don't know if we're there yet um
the uh look all i get from that story is
nemours coming and that's what i'm happy
about like
you know who plays them neither here nor
there
to me just get in the more you can
um i want to see what marvel does with
the with the with the ocean
we've seen what what dc does with the
sea let's see what marvel does with the
oceans
um we saw what they did with space so i
can't wait to see what they do and you
know nemours
generally has short hair so they ain't
got to worry about this [ __ ]
they could save a few bucks without
having to [ __ ] worry about this [ __ ]
that's this is me miming hair in the
floating in the air mark
it's very good i like it thank you
um it's a little vanna white it's a
little
um i'm yeah i'm ready for it and stuff i
i you know
it's is the is the question like
is that like are people happy about that
guy are unhappy about that guy are they
like we want somebody more famous than
that guy or something
i i i think there was there's a little
bit of
i think there had been some some
controversy around that actor for
reasons that i don't know and didn't dig
that deep into
but i think that there had been a if not
a belief
at least a a fond desire um on the part
of lots of asian marvel fans
who always felt that submariner had been
portrayed in the comics as a person of
asian descent
um so there's a lot of like are we gonna
get daniel dick him are we gonna get
like can we get can this be what we
think it is going to be
um but because i don't know if this
actor is the person they cast
it might be a little premature
everybody's down for namor
um and i think maymore namor comes to
marvel the same way that the hulk comes
to marvel
which is there's a like it's a character
controlled by another movie studio i
think universal is that right like they
can't do a flat out in a more movie
right i think universal has the rights
to name oil much of the way they have
the rights of the hulk
which is why you're never going to see a
hulk movie um a hulk standalone movie
um and you're also never going to see a
name or standalone movie not that they
do lots of villain movies but you
wouldn't see that anyway
um but yeah everybody's down for some
for some sub marination
i'm into it man i can't wait that i like
to
i've seen all the narcos i'm not sure
who's who they picked to play um
namor or namor but uh
i uh you know i'm in i don't care who
they cast just get them in a movie quick
give it to me yeah give it to me baby
fast
cheap and out of control no i want it
um what else is going on in the news uh
rumor of the week number two
is that zack snyder hot off of
uh army of the dead dominating on
netflix and the snyder cut
um is being courted by sony
and their sony pictures universe of
marvel characters which i didn't realize
was a thing
at least according to we got this
covered is an actual thing with
uh you know uppercases um that zack
snyder is being courted
to make a spider universe film oh that's
cool
yeah he should do it i'm sure he'll do
it i mean yeah
what am i talking about i don't know i'm
like i'm sure he'll do it but if i was
him
i'd be like well like in a world where
like you know they don't want me over
there [ __ ] yeah i'll jump over to marvel
i mean that's what they used to do in
comics right the creator would
leave one of the big two and jump to the
other and stuff
that'd be a smart move man plus fun for
fandom
you know people be like like ooh
he's he's a man who walks between two
worlds
three if you count the zombie verse and
[ __ ] like that
yeah the sony is sony is all in
on making movies about spider-man minor
characters
venom let there be carnage is is coming
soon morbius
is arriving in january of next year at
some point
did they say who's making craven um jc
chandor
oh that's right he made him always lost
yeah and he also made i think margin
call as well
yeah um has iron tara johnson playing
craven hunter olivia wilde is still
working on
what may or may not be spider woman um
as the the writer the director at the
very least um so yeah they're all about
kind of fleshing out things that might
lead them to their sinister six
that they're they're kind of hoping for
and so sure man why not get zach
in there to do some to have some fun but
it is at this point just a rumor uh many
people in the chat asking over and over
either that or it's
andrew crosby asking over and over
what's with the head dance
when mark is talking kev um people
see me do that all the time
um i don't know kids it's nothing really
it's
uh one of those like you know you could
either do nothing or you could do
something
so rather than just you know
i mean this is not a political statement
or slam but rather than just tucker
carlson
and be like you know i just i'd rather
just keep my head kind of moving and
stuff and
slowly bopping and also at the root of
it like this is
me having a good time like i'm like i
enjoy this i like this show like i'm
this is a good use of my time
i'm having i'm having a good time by
myself but i'm with friends
so anybody like the questions like chair
dancing
a little like uh jerome a little bit
yes a little bit yes yes very much
later on at one point i'll be bringing
mark amir
[Laughter]
um what else we got uh
liam neeson was on uh jimmy kimmel this
week to uh
to sadly shatter some dreams that there
will be no qui-gon
in the new star wars kenobi disney plus
series
why uh according to him they don't have
enough money
are you rea did he say that he's like
[ __ ] qui-gon don't get out of bed for
less than a quarter bill
wow man really yeah i mean i think it
was a joke but he's like i heard ewan
was going to do a series and
he doesn't think he's going to be in it
because he hasn't been approached to be
in it
um you think he's serious you know
banff oh banff man is is here he's
filtering on star wars here he comes
i will say he did do the voice of
qui-gon
in the last episodes of clone wars now
i understand voiceover is different he
can record it from
on his iphone from a closet anywhere in
the world
but it doesn't seem to reason that he
would agree to come back to do qui-gon
to
in uh in animated form
and then be like well if you want the
guy who's done
taking one through 14 you
you really you've gotta you gotta pay up
listen to [ __ ] listen to banff man
throwing shade and then
swinging out of gotham holy [ __ ]
took a pit stop with the salt lick
before he banted in here the [ __ ]
poor liam neeson somewhere it's like am
i bleeding i think i've been attacked
um i yeah i mean look i don't need i'd
be shocked if they didn't
if he don't show up in season one trust
me
they do a season two they'll probably
[ __ ] get him right they'll probably
be like look we gotta go qui-gon now
we shot our [ __ ] wad yeah with mara
jade or whatever the [ __ ] not married
that's luke's wife who's the who's the
girl that
what is it cara dune no we can't do cara
dude i don't think that was it
um but you know it's it's like cobra kai
remember like season two they were like
now we're going to japan
like same thing i think or season three
or did they go to japan regardless
they're gonna
if they don't have qui-gon in season one
it gives them some place to go in season
two
right if there is going to be a season
two and these things could be mini
series
for with a closed end for all we know
it's true that could be like wanda
visions but also like the last thing
that
yoda told obi-wan was like i'm gonna
teach you how to go commune with the
dead
uh you go take this kid to his uncle
so communing with the dead would seem to
have something to do with qui-gon
that's true i wonder if they'd ever be
ballsy enough to like be like all right
[ __ ] it let's just let's get a cheaper
quagon
let's get discount qui-gon who's this
take me away qui-gon qui-gon take me
away
who is the like if you can't get liam
neeson
who's the substitute liam neeson what's
tim roth doing
tim really is that the is that the go-to
there's there's so
it's a big difference in height between
those two goods quite a bit
stand them in a box um yeah that's true
you could always put on an apple box
um yeah i don't know something tells me
like they love doing fan service over
there you mean to tell me [ __ ] uh
what's his name dave uh filoni
was gonna like let that not happen like
like qui-gon is one of george's boys man
george created that character
so you better be damn skippy they'll
probably labor to get that character in
man if he if he i don't know [ __ ] from
[ __ ] and i don't know anybody but
come on look what they did man they got
[ __ ] luke skywalker back for the
mandalorian for heaven's sakes
you don't think they're gonna like go
for a qui-gon sooner or later i think
there's there's something there's
something that's tickling me about liam
neeson just being
like i don't want to [ __ ] do it it's
like we gotta have you in it
i just don't want it i mean we already
got one harrison ford in the world
we don't need two we don't need another
guy gone nope
nope nope i'm done with that you know
remember harrison ford was like i'm done
with star wars and then he came back
to be a force ghost kind of yep
see how much do you think they paid him
i mean it was the last one right
supposed to be like the last the final
of the skywalker
you know and this again i don't know
[ __ ] this is just guesswork but like
what would make
harrison ford show up for literally one
day of work
god i gotta guess minimum 10 million
minimum that's about right
right like say 20. oh
man is here and he might have some
inside hello back
in oh gosh 2013
2014 i had heard a rumor and i can't
remember who i heard it from
that uh that mark hamill
carrie fisher and harrison ford all
signed
a three picture deal for 10 million
dollars per picture
so a 30 million dollar deal 10 million
dollars
per movie that they were in of the new
movies of the new
yes for seven eight and nine
and i think i actually heard
that they signed that with
george and lucasfilm before the disney
sale
so that it had to be like so that they
had to get paid
but i can't remember i don't remember
where i heard that but i
i know i definitely heard that amount of
money
for each of those guys i mean 10 million
sounds about right
but then again like bruce willis is
still getting like
two or three million dollars to do a
day's worth of work on some weird-ass
croatian action movie just to put his
face on the cover so i feel like you
could probably if you're harrison ford
going to come back for a sound solo
even for a scene you could get more than
10 million
um and hopefully it's i want you to
donate 25 million dollars to this
school or this charity or this whatever
like
you're harrison ford man i mean look
you know how expensive it must be to be
harrison ford
but he's been that for a long time he's
gotten good at it
keeps working man so you know that to me
says
i got bills i mean that's why i work
you gotta pay my automobiles you gotta
pay my telephone bills
gene hackman stopped working stopped
being an actor started writing books
91 he's written three best sellers i
just read that today because we lost the
late great ned beatty today yes we'll
get into the net of it all
we'll get into that later on all right
what's next
uh aquaman 2 not much news besides
it's got a title now oh what are they
calling it it is now
aquaman and the lost kingdom of the
crystal skull
well that worked out for the other guys
i'm sure it'll work out great
aquaman in the lost kingdom and the last
kingdom yeah is that referred to the
lost kingdom of atlantis you think
um could be except like how they were
just there in the first movie did they
lose
where'd it go hey who took my latest
um are they shooting yet um
let me see i believe they've begun
pre-production
same director james wong
is indeed back in the seat uh jason
kidd is so talented so talented that
that last aquaman movie while it was
very long
was very well done i thought it felt
like they were like we got to put
everything in because we may not get to
do this again
and to doing so like created a monster
hit so they'll get to make a few of
these and stuff so i look forward to see
what he does
yeah i mean the first aquaman released
in december of 2018
grossed more than a billion dollars
which was the only dc film outside of
nolan's dark knight trilogy
to hit that mark that right yeah wonder
woman didn't do it
nope interesting um
i uh yeah i i'm i'm all for it i don't
know where you go after that last one
though
i mean again i just watched it fairly
recently with with jennifer she'd never
seen it
my wife and uh my god she was just like
how many movies is this i was like if
this is one movie like
and they put everything in they put in
orem ocean master they put in black
manta
they did his origins like it's crazy
they got it all in there man
so you know if if uh if it's warner
brothers and his comic book movie and
and so naturally i'm sure they're like
the next one's gotta be even bigger but
it's like
how the [ __ ] do you do that that movie
seemed
huge to me really big really ambitious
so i'm but i'm there i'll buy
i'll buy ticket and [ __ ]
that's my promise that's my hot take
right write that up comicbook.com
i'll buy a ticket says kev in regard
comic book movie it'll be things kevin
smith will buy a ticket for and then
every comic book movie ever made what
else we got
um marvel she-hulk is getting a villain
uh jamila jamil who was on who was
amazing on the good place has joined the
cast
of the she-hulk according to the
hollywood reporter
and she will be playing titania
a villain from the comics um dates back
to actually secret wars number three
where titanic was introduced
by a gym shooter and artist mike zeck
wow a mike zec creation
with kim's scooter wow
unfamiliar with this character as am i
um despite the fact that circuit wars
was my entree to marvel comics
um it's been quite a while since i read
the secret wars
probably worth a reread uh matt
shavarian chad says what are you
drinking on kev this
is uh mooby's cannabis seltzer
by the good folks at uh mighty kind uh
it's violet mango i was drinking
another mango before uh tropical mango
but uh no calories plant-based
it's got some [ __ ] cannabis seltzer
you know i like i like that sort of
thing
there you go so i don't drink [ __ ] with
sugar in it anymore so this is
this is as fun as it gets for me
all right back to you my friend um let's
see a couple of quick development
things no sony pictures in blumhouse are
revving up christine a remake of the
stephen king novel
who's doing it um blumen house
i love that book yes brian fuller
is writing and directing making his
features brian fuller of
pushing daisies approaching daisies and
american gods and hannibal and heroes
indeed
he's the man um i uh i'm on board for
that man
the [ __ ] you got to give it to the
[ __ ] mark yeah you can't let the
[ __ ]
take advantage of you in this world
that was that's from the book remember
the guy sells in the car was all about
the [ __ ] and then later on
rd becomes about what was his was his
name arthur no was his name
i think it is yeah i just remember keith
gordon
was playing gordon played him yeah he
wasn't going to be a
fancy-ass movie director a j he is a
fancy ass movie director uh john
carpenter made
christine yeah 1983. killer car movie
maybe the best of the killer car move
the haunted car the possessed
machine um she spoke using songs on the
radio
kind of like bumblebee the proto
bumblebee
that's how they should sell this movie
it's the scary bumblebee kids
[Laughter]
the car don't transform but the terror
will transform you
um you do that movie inexpensively do
you think they'll make it the same
you know [ __ ] car whatever it was
like a 57 chevy or some sort of [ __ ]
i think they very much want it a fuller
wanted to be an 80s period piece
and so i think that if you don't make it
a 58 plymouth fury
then uh kind of what's the point
you know what brian fuller show me your
balls
make it a hugo make christine a
[ __ ] hugo it's a ford pinto
with the devil inside better yet make it
one of them [ __ ] scooters that tom
hanks drove in that movie that one time
you know eat one of those [ __ ]
he's like me and me and christine we
didn't like the [ __ ] and
guys like and christine is what you
named your scooter
me and christine we don't like the
[ __ ]
who are the [ __ ] again anybody don't
ride a vespa
[Applause]
that's the song i remember on the radio
yeah my boyfriend's back
wow on his best
he cuts christine jokes that's what you
come to
fat man beyond to listen to kids um well
i'm i'm
down for that that's a that's a stephen
king remake i'd like to see
indeed and you know doing it for
bloomberg house doing it smart and cheap
make it scary here for it
uh speaking of making it scary rob
zombie
is going to be remaking the monsters
what what a great story this was man
number one i think rob zombie is a
really good filmmaker i [ __ ] like the
way he shoots i think he's a really good
competition man good shooter and stuff
um but like when i heard this i was
you know i was like oh is it gonna be
you know [ __ ] like a really dark
sinister version which they did at one
point didn't they do a tv
show called like 13 13 mockingbird lane
or something like that yeah i think
they tried it seriously or something but
he said he indicate he said
like this is something uh my dream
project i've been chasing for 30 years
or something like that
so i i think it's i think that's such a
great idea i look forward to see what he
does that's that's
universal doing that um yeah it'll
stream most likely on peacock
um is that right yeah
yeah yeah it's is it a show or a movie
i think it's a movie i think it's a
movie but um
backdoor pilot which sounds dirtier than
i meant it
i mean i hope it's as dirty exactly as
you meant it but um
i don't i don't know it could be it
could very well be oh my god
uh in chat braden goss just said brian
fuller
who we were just talking about he's the
one that made 1313 mockingbird
yeah with eddie izzard i think as uh as
herman munster
german guy i mean he's brian fuller
[ __ ] makes a lot of stuff doesn't he
he's had his hands in
quite a few pots always busy man he's
like a like a mini berlanti of sorts
um somebody keeps telling us to stop
hitting the microphones i didn't know
that we were doing that but
i'd also just like to point out kids you
can't make demands
of a free show you may suggest all you
like but you can't demand
that we stop hitting the mic unless
you want to give us some money you want
to give us some money not to use the mic
or
hit the mic hit that mic
did it guys like no
no um
okay uh what uh what else we got up next
is a is a thing that you you nobody chat
is asking you
mark when is adora dropping on
comixology mark's got a
uh graphic novel coming out correct mark
indeed yeah uh tuesday
tuesday the 15th um adora in the
distance will be available
to anybody who has access to comixology
um
i think it's even part of the kindle
reads program
um but it's the it's in the amazon
ecosystem which means i'm sure you can
get it 98 different ways but yes the
digital releases is tuesday
and so far um the the word the word
spilling forth from people who have read
it has been um
overwhelmingly positive which uh which
makes me feel real good
[ __ ] hey look at that you love mark
support him man go get his goddamn book
uh ad wolf media corrected us and said
eddie izzard played grandpa
in mockingbird lane not herman
uh you reached uh before we jump into
jump into the other story you reached
your your splinter
uh uh campaign is over now not yet we
got three more days
um we hit 200 grand
um we're now at 212. 212
000. well i know who i'm gonna start
[ __ ] hitting up for
money for my movies well hello mr
moneybags mr monopoly mr
mr [ __ ] jp moneybags wow look at that
and what was the dream you wanted to get
to like 90 something
90 was the goal the hope was 140
um to be able to do everything that we
needed to do
anything above and beyond that was just
going to make it easier we can pay the
crew
more we can have a couple more shooting
days if we need them
um when we hit 200 000 i said that i
would do a
black man beyond special in which i
i re-review which i
i i kind of i i go hard
in the sexiest way possible on the the
zack snyder's justice league oh this guy
the internet's waiting for this that's
why they gave you all that money they're
like eat crow
say things you don't believe you son of
a [ __ ]
um when are you gonna do that uh i think
probably at some point
um while you're gone back east um
and we we may or may not need to uh to
have some new content in the feed
i will uh i will give it another
re-watch i will have my notebook out to
take notes
and uh and then render unto caesar what
is his
slash theirs um
the santo hartano
says and uh i i don't know
if this is uh true this is the chat on
uh the uh
youtube channel kids some people in the
chat are like what chat is he looking at
it's your chat
uh they said can we talk about christina
ricci being cast as morticia in the new
netflix
um wednesday adam show is that true
i don't know i know she was just cast in
the in the matrix i'd read that this
week
was she also cast as morgicia because
that would be fantastic
uh kabuki kid in chat is asking about
where the jeff's kiss shirts are
i'm telling you i don't know i don't
know how many [ __ ] ways i could say
this kids
this shirt has been such a [ __ ] nut
biter
barn burner like we can't get it going
it's coming soon i promise though i
promise
uh jordan told me that it's absolutely
coming
um and let's see according to
screenrant.com a story from may
3rd 2021 the netflix's adam's
family tv show reportedly eyeing
christina ricci to play morticia
um it doesn't say that she has been
signed
oh wait hey this is according to the
illuminati again
who seems to have uh information that
nobody else has
um like it we don't have to be right
we're reporting on some
other someone else is reporting it we
can just make some [ __ ] up
k rogers in chat points out that today
is the birthdays of chris evans
captain america kat dennings plays darcy
lewis
in juan division and aaron taylor
johnson
mr quicksilver slash future craven
himself all three of them
at birthdays this weekend or today
america's ass god bless him
america's ass indeed all right what else
we got
oh batman is in here he swings in
america's ass and kick
ass have birthdays
yes aaron good point man that's true
i can't believe it damn just to say that
you could have posted that in chat jc
[ __ ] um what else what other news
um i remember uh back low
many moons ago um uh at least one person
on this podcast
had been in early development on a
salmon twitch
television show i was
involved with a sam and twitch tv show
it almost went at bbc america a few
years ago i was
hired uh to write a script and i wrote a
script which i enjoyed very much and
they enjoyed very much and then bbc
america
had their budget slashed that year um
and so the show went away um
and at one point they were trying to
revive it someplace else but but we
never got past the script but there was
a script
but i understand now that uh i think i
read online that they're
todd is moving forward with another
version with somebody involved
with mayor of east town is that correct
the whip
wiip the independent studio behind
maravi's town
is partnering with with mcfarland for a
new salmon twitch
um there's no place yet there's no
network
currently uh mentioned as a destination
for it
but uh jason smylovic and todd
katzenberg
who crea created and ran epex's condor
series
are adapting the project as well as
serving as executive producers
right on somebody asked who i saw as my
ass sam and twitch
uh i would have liked uh dave dismalchin
as my coach and um
uh ty tyler
um lebinsky those name from uh
from um reaper my boy you know who was
in he was in uh
um zachary make a porno he was like hug
it chug it football
he would have been my sam and dave
desponsion would have been my twitch
um but yes that's that sounds like
they're going forward with another
version of that they are indeed um no
real
indicators on what this version is going
to look like um
but we we may have a chance of seeing
the same twitch tv show at some point
uh aj ash mars mariscal
in in chat says bbc the network not the
online category yeah it was for bbc
america kids i should be very specific
about that
it was the same network that was doing
the dirk gently
show and they were doing um black orphan
black as well and so the idea was orphan
black was coming to an end and they
wanted something to slot
into you know follow it when it was gone
and that was going to be sam and twitch
um but it went away and now there'll be
another version perhaps coming
welcome to hollywood boys and girls um
what else we got
um there is a new what
somebody in chat i've i lost the thread
but they said we should never banff
shane they're saying that i
bam shaved tyler levine i said ty
lubinski what an idiot tyler levine yes
um yeah sorry bam
man we didn't mean to bam shame you for
yes he will he won't damp anymore if we
can
we can't have that can't [ __ ] make
him you know
too self-conscious about bamfing in and
[ __ ] he'll be like dumbo
like unwilling to come out of his cage
then we'll have to stick a magic feather
in his ass and that'll
[Laughter]
here's the thing if the next show is at
the
cantina i don't know how i'm going to
bamf
into the actual world unless i become a
mutant
well you have to you you uh i mean you
still in the old show you would pop onto
the screen and stuff like that
where you would cut to yourself so
whenever
you you'll have to yell bamf okay
well we're going to lose the graphic
though i think yeah i tried to figure it
out
but you should go to a magic store and
just buy some [ __ ] smoke pellets
so when you're about to banff just
that would actually be like batman i
could you know what what if i
bought a like a smoke machine i put it
at the floor
where i stand and every time i hit bamf
i went
and smoke shot up better yet we put a we
dr
curtain in front of your booth one
that's like attached to the top
and then whenever you bamp you it just
drops and
hits the ground you go bam and then when
we go back to us you slowly pull it back
up well everybody watches you like reset
the pants
it's loud as [ __ ]
[Music]
um what other stories we got uh new line
cinema is partnering with warner
animation to make an original brand new
lord of the rings
animated movie called war of the
rohirrim
now i know you have deep love for these
movies kevin
uh yeah i mean look i've seen them but
they're just not uh
ironically enough they they the lord of
the rings movies
deeply informed uh our masters of the
universe revelation
project uh because everyone in the
writers room accept me
were big rings nerds so they were like
well in a world where we're doing a
fellowship movie
we have to follow these things and so
there's a lot of
reference to those movies and stuff yeah
to which kevin would say
no we don't yeah like did you i don't
know if you know that but
all those movies were about walking even
the [ __ ] trees walk they're like
we saw the movie [ __ ] we all
saw clerks too thank you in any event so
there's a good
cartoon not since the great ralph bakshi
has there been a lord of the ranks
cartoon is that true i believe that to
be true
a tolkien cartoon and what his story are
they telling
uh they're telling the story uh behind
helms deep
the fortress depicted in lord of the
rings the two towers and
about the man in whose honor it is named
helm
hammerhand who's not a porn star but
actually
the legendary king of rohan who spent
much of his reign locked
in a prolonged and costly war um
it is part of the the peter jackson lord
of the rings universe
in as much as they're using some of
their designs and and and
narrative inspiration from lord of the
rings but philippa bullions who won an
oscar for co-writing the screenplay
is consulting on the project it has
nothing to do
with amazon's lord of the rings show
which takes place
millennia prior to these events um
but they're doing their best to put this
movie on the fast track so that it can
be released
probably somewhere around the same time
as amazon's low the ring show
because they're not done um com
comic quirks with jimmy says mark when
is season two of carnival row coming out
because i know you worked on it did you
work on that
i did yes like two years ago
a while ago right but that was season
two and that still hasn't happened yet
yeah when i when i left they had started
production on season two
they had some bumps in production they
slowed it down
um there had been another version of a
writing staff that had been brought on
i'm probably tongue tales out of school
but they also can't fire me because i
quit a long time ago um
but the hand that feeds bite the hand
[Laughter]
but i know that uh and they had to stop
production on that second season for
covid colgate had prague pretty hard and
shut everything down
and so i know that the cast uh at least
from what i can tell
um on their instagram stories are
returning to set
this week to resume production on season
two of carnival so
hopefully uh you might see it maybe by
the beginning of
2022 given how long these things take
but it's coming
it's a comment i don't know why i got
excited i didn't watch carnival
and then i was like wait what are we
talking about oh sex fairies
is that what that shows about there's
some sexy fairies
and fairies who have sex for money
perhaps i'm going to have to correct
this
the next deep dive i'll be doing with my
wife i'm like there's a sex fairy show
i bet you jen would like it quite a bit
really
yeah she don't like old timey [ __ ]
jen like old-timey [ __ ] she's not she
really
generalized but she every once in a
while i'll put on something she's like
this is old
they're riding horses i don't want to be
with them and riding horses she don't go
for that she's like you know give me a
car
but like you know like yeah she might go
for it
was she a game of thrones person she's
uh i showed her key
moments but she we have not done the
show i think there's far
too much
non-consensual sex involved in that show
for
her taste yeah yeah
she she'd have to wade through that a
little too much to get to the dragons
and
i don't think she'd she'd make it what
about the crown was she a crown person
we did watch the crown but not while it
like when it was happening live we
watched that during the pandemic and
[ __ ] like when they dropped the
princess diana season i was like hey man
let's try this and then we were like oh
[ __ ] let's go back and then we watched
it in reverse order
gotcha um but yeah and i remember saying
to her i was like i thought you didn't
like
old-timey [ __ ] she's like what the [ __ ]
up
[Laughter]
they use phones they drive in cars
they wear the thing that captured her
imagination about the queen was
uh about the crown rather was that uh
whenever she's [ __ ] done with
somebody she just rings that bell
she won't even say like the meeting's
over or something she rings the bell and
they're like oh
oh sorry and they just get up and
[ __ ] bow and go and [ __ ] she was like
i'm putting a bell on this [ __ ] desk
she's like when i'm done with you i'm
just gonna look at you and press it
i'm sorry mom oh you finished with me
yet yeah truly really
i couldn't call her mom that'd be weird
um all right what else we got
our final story um before we get into
the q a
is the sad passing of the great ned
beatty
we lost a great one the great ned beatty
baby uh who of course
uh you know there's a huge body of work
uh
uh network he's amazing in uh of course
uh
uh deliverance very memorable in and
whatnot but for
our world um he was otis
to lex gene hackman's lex luthor yes
the greatest criminal mind of this
century
hired one of the [ __ ] dumbest
sidekicks
of all time loyal but not [ __ ] real
bright man
i got your paper mr luthor um he was a
welcome uh
uh respite in uh superman because uh
you know he was fun for kids as well
whereas you know gene hackman of course
was much more grown up an adult but otis
was
you know kind of on our level very much
so
um also lotso bear right from
schindler's toy box yes lots of hugging
uh the villain of toy story three
yeah ned beatty um he was
in the first captain america movie uh
the one was the motorcycle in america
the one with the motorcycle
yep the tv one yeah he was captain
america's best friend
who who was that bucky
no i don't think that beatty was playing
bucky
um he was also dancing with the soldier
dan connor's dad back in the day
he was in the toy that's right he was
the
the dad in the toy right um no the devil
that was john that was uh jackie gleason
who was jackie gleason he was jackie
gleason's like
business manager or whatever who uh who
who was the one like charged with buying
the toy
slash you know a slave for this young
child
not a movie they'll be remaking anytime
soon he's in the incredible shrinking
woman he was in
silver streak all the president's men
back to school
rudy charlie wilson's war rango
he got one oscar nomination for a
network
for network um and a an mtv movie award
for lots of hug and bear
he got an mtv movie award for that role
he did uh
you know he he was he was an actor who
worked quite a bit
there were something like 160 credits in
film and tv between 72 and 2003 when he
sort of retired
he was on the waltons gunsmoke mash
rockford file streets in san francisco
murder she wrote alfred hitchcock
presents
roseanne homicide life on the street um
yes he was he was hollywood's greatest
schlub and uh and he will be
fondly missed the epitome of a character
actor ralph
uh ralph jesus mark
sunday night at 10 17 baby it's all
happening
it's all there's what was the line in
the
last temptation of christ there's one
woman in the world one woman
with many faces in my world it's there's
one co-host in the world
one of those
where else are we is that it that's the
end of our news my friend
um what a what a wonderful actor he was
uh
and in many roles touched our [ __ ]
lives and stuff like that
um guys like that actors like that
cartilage
in movies kids you know not the not the
skull not the [ __ ] hand or the foot
or the dick bone any of those [ __ ]
like showy parts
is the cartilage inside it's what holds
it all together
keeps them bones together that's who ned
beatty was goddamn cartilage the
movie business man he'll be missed
um shamey's past all right
that's all the news that's all the news
as we would say on babylon a huge bucket
of wind that like bucket of wind
there's one thing i wanted to plug
before we run away it has nothing to do
with me other than i like it very much
yes but uh your friend in mind bear
mccreary
yes that's the composer from masters
universe revelation
and many many many other things but um
he came to prominence his very first job
at a college
he was on a little show called
battlestar galactica and
he uh at the height of the show i think
in the final season
used to go on tour with like a
band he put together that would just
perform battlestar galactica live
um and it was a lot rockier and poundier
and drummier
than the the soundtracks that you might
remember from the show and
he has just released an album of that
music called so say we all
battlestar galactica live which you can
get streaming anywhere
you can buy it anywhere you'd buy a
thing i think he's selling autographed
copies
um if you go to bear mccreary dot com
you can find all that information
but any any chance to spread the bear
love
is a chance worth taking so if you're if
you're a lover of his music
as we all are um listen to that album
because it's a
it is a big bucket of win um you're not
kidding man i was with
uh bear just this week i went over to
his studio
and we shot a video about uh you know
all the
soundtrack stuff about all the score for
uh masters of the universe revelation
and uh while he we were there like we
were chit-chatting and [ __ ]
and uh you know we were talking about
battle star because
that's what put him on my [ __ ] radar
and
you know then i was like when when it
came time to score this show we were all
all of us were like bear mccreary bear
mccreary
um but i said like he was telling the
story about
like i was like so what had you done
before
battlestar galactica and he was like
that was my first job
and i was like what like how old were
he's like i was 24.
i was like how did you get a [ __ ] tv
show he's like i was assisting the
person who did the score for the pilot
and then they took off after that or
whatever and he said so
for the first like almost two years the
show
every week they'd be like hey can you do
this and he'd be like
all right but they never hired him to be
the composer so he was always like
i thought i'd get fired every single
week like sooner or later they'd find
the right person and they'd take the job
but then you know it's like the dread
pirate roberts where it's like all right
wesley
you know good job i hope i may kill you
in the morning so like he just never
knew
that he was the guy until one day they
were like oh yeah you're the guy
and he became a permanent guy but at age
24 dude
super young yeah and that's an
accomplished
score like an insanely accomplished
score that
stands up today and you can hear it as
mark said
on an album called so say we all is it
on spotify
it's on spotify it's on pandora it may
or may not be on myspace i don't know
but uh it's definitely available any
place that you buy and or stream your
music
go uh if you love bear and you'll i was
gonna say if you love a score for
master's universe but you haven't heard
it yet he is doing uh no [ __ ] career
best work
with his masters in the universe
revelation score which you're gonna hear
like crazy in the story trailer you know
uh when it when it drops
um if you love him if you loved anything
he's ever done
agent's shield [ __ ] lander
you know so for a child's play uh go
give him some love man go buy that album
and [ __ ]
hell yeah i'm such a good dude such a
good dude my guy he's he's like
going beyond above and beyond for his
masters
of the universe score um it's
yeah and he's just the sweetest man like
any sweet man too when we were doing the
battlestar galactica podcast um
you know i asked him i was like hey man
listen do you have any music lying
around
you know some snippet of a thing that
you wrote that got cut out of an episode
like we're just looking for a theme
for the podcast and like we're just
looking for something that feels like
battlestar hopefully you just have
something that
that you can just dig out of the files
it's like well give me a little bit let
me see what i can find
and then like a day later he said you
know
i just figured i'd write you a new thing
and then he sends me like a
mp3 or whatever of this amazing 60
second piece of music that he just
ginned together
on a [ __ ] lark because he was like
yeah you know it's yours
you know do with it what you want could
you imagine having that much talent to
spare where you're like here's a whole
[ __ ] score yeah just here you go
wrote you a brand new thing david young
is asking uh kevin please ask
mark for an update about star trek
picard have they shot any episodes he
wrote yet
are you writing on season three as well
um picard is currently in production on
season two
um i don't know where in production they
are because i
i am no longer engaged in the picard
universe
um you know which is no fault of
anybody's you know it is not uh
i didn't get fired i didn't quit in a
huff but
tv work is is contract work it is always
um they they engage you for a certain
number of weeks
um and then at the end of those weeks
it's like thanks very much for playing
if the timing works out that there can
be a third season or a fourth season or
fifth season then that's a negotiation
that we can have
um but my i had obligations to fulfill
so when i finished my duty in starfleet
in my second season
and then mustered out and then and then
moved on to the next thing
um which i can't talk about yet i don't
think
um but it's fun and it's cool
um and it may or may not have a its own
little baby battlestar connection
um but um but yeah the time that i spent
in the final frontier was that was time
well spent
in the final frontier um but since i'm
no longer on the show i have no idea
how much of what i did will survive the
process because tv is a ravenous beast
that sometimes masticates more than it
preserves so uh
so we'll see what happens but i'm
excited for it because if it's anything
like what i remember
we worked on i think fans will have a
blast with it
and q is coming back so how's that a bad
thing does everybody know that
yes i i didn't stop like holy [ __ ]
we just we broke a story our two and a
half into a podcast
was coming back uh chase cornett in
uh the chat says you are kev are you
excited for the pop-up next week i know
it's like the umpteenth one but are you
hyped for it
um the movies pop-up moves to oklahoma
city
um we're uh let's see we're finishing up
the milwaukee movies pop-up both of them
are at places called the
up down um and yeah so
oklahoma city is on sale now and i think
oklahoma city counts as our
i want to say i think boston was the
13th i think it's our 15th
uh movies pop-up so if you're anywhere
near okc and you want to jump in
tickets at moviespopup.com also
kids uh lots of tickets coming up we're
getting back out into the real world and
[ __ ] as we said before
we're going to be doing a fat man beyond
uh live again
you know cantina um this week we put
tickets on sale
coming up this week for uh um
the grand opening of smod castle podcast
theater that i have back in new jersey
which is in the
quick stop building where quick stop you
know convenience store is
um so tickets will be going on for sale
for that and right now
tickets are on sale for uh clerk
the documentary about my life that
played at south by southwest mark is in
the documentary as well
malcolm ingram directed it we're taking
it out on tour
in november so we're going right now the
dates are the cities are
austin asbury park which is in new
jersey
of course um the uh the
st louis chicago vancouver i know
toronto is going to be added and stuff
so if you want to go see the screening
of clerk and then me and malcolm come
out and q
a afterwards uh in november when we're
you know of i guess even more open
hopefully than we are now and stuff like
that
if you want to sit in a theater around
other people again like we used to back
in good old 2019 come on
out and see the flag it's warm it's
wonderful if it's not playing in any of
those cities near you don't worry it'll
be
coming to streaming of course but in
november you can come see us tickets at
csmodd.com
right now uh okay we got another sponsor
as we talked about kids
for the second half of the show and
that's gonna lead us into our q a
as previously mentioned it's the 40th
anniversary
of raiders of the lost ark man and when
we get into the q a the best
question this night is going to get that
package that you can see right there
comes with everything you see here no
assembly required this fat ass
box set that paramount put together four
movie
collection man uh what do they got on
that
let me pull it up they they sent us the
the thing here's listen to everything
it's got on it
the indiana jones four movie collection
includes a collectible booklet with
behind the scenes images from
all four films each film is presented on
4k
ultra hd blu-ray disc with original
theatrical trailers and access to
digital copies
the set also includes a blu-ray with
seven hours of previously
uh released bonus content as detailed
below so
all the [ __ ] they ever put out they're
including in this thing
um so you got from jungle the desert
from adventure to legend making the
films the making of raiders of the lost
ark the 1981 documentary
that like that i remember that showed us
how
they flipped a truck and how it was a
stunt guy getting dragged through a
gully in the ground like behind the
truck
amazing behind the scenes special that i
guarantee you is responsible for many
film careers man because they showed you
like how stuff was done
and knowledge is power if you could see
it you could be it so that that's a very
powerful
document for change bunch of [ __ ] uh
indiana jones behind the scenes temple
of doom last crusade behind the scenes
the stunts of indy jones the sound of
indy jones the music of indy jones the
light and magic of indiana jones
raiders the melting face so many
different
uh behind the scenes packages man if you
love indiana jones you're gonna
you're just gonna you're gonna have them
all over your face neck and chest with
this amazing
box set man do you remember uh
seeing raiders of lost ark for the first
time i do
very vividly like that was the first
movie that taught me that i was a wussy
when it came to gore like i was not
prepared for
melting faces everything else is fine
you know like i could deal with spiders
and snakes
and boulders and even you know what's
his face getting
poked through the back of the head with
pungy sticks as
andy gets his whip back all of that i
could uh i could i could totally swing
with but it was the melty facey [ __ ]
that i was not prepared to encounter as
at that point
a i don't know 10 year old kid um
i i don't think anybody's 10 year old
kid was prepared for that
uh i was hiding in the back of my
parents car then we started a
drive-through
at a drive-in and i was just back behind
the seats i was like
not having this this is too much for me
and uh and that would color my feeling
towards most horror
um for the rest of my life don't want
that i like everything else don't need
that
um but that said i then saw the movie
500 more times over the years because it
is a perfect perfect film
even though spoiler alert indiana jones
does not do
anything to stop the nazis from doing
everything they're going to do
indiana jones is at most inconvenience
but never an actual hindrance
because the nazi plan was always let's
take this thing to the desert
open it up and see what happens which
they do
yeah i said it's still a phenomenal
movie it is a great movie and there have
been
of course many internet articles about
like if you take indiana jones out of
raiders of lost ark
everything still happens um and they're
right and i've read somebody's take on
that was like
that's kind of the point the point is
indy had to like that was indy's whole
character arc is to see
that like he had no effect on things
that
the power of the ark the power of god
was always
[ __ ] in charge i don't know if i
agree with that take but i thought it
was an interesting take where i was like
all right
all right like they're like that's his
character i'm a guy who goes like
i don't believe in this [ __ ] to a
guy who's like i you close your eyes
marion
like because the power of god is killing
nazis in the [ __ ] desert banff man
you have a take on this
uh you're uh your friend in mind
christopher drake
film composer uh wonderful uh he sent
out a tweet
i believe it was him who said uh
somebody brought that up and he goes
yeah but he does save marion from
getting her face
burned off and tortured by the nazis in
nepal
so he is a hero just very early on in
the movie
yes and his sakes are not i'm going to
save the world
so the hitler doesn't get this it's i
just got to save this one lady
who i probably slept with when she was a
child and i was a grown-ass man
that's right the box set from our
sponsor paramount ladies and gentlemen
the good folks who want you to enjoy
raiders of the lost park and all these
jones the best question of the night
will discover for themselves
if she was a child when she was in love
or not she saw
she uh talked about that recently i
guess like this week on there's an
article where
like karen allen weighs in on on the
marion and indiana jones thing
um i remember going to see this movie
like i did not want to see this movie as
much as i wanted to see superman 2
which i believe was out at roughly the
same time um they had a
movie book for superman 2 that like we
went to see raiders the lost ark and i
begged my dad to buy it
and he was like don't you want the movie
book for raiders of the lost ark and i
was like no
i want the movie book for superman too
so i went into
raiders of the lost ark completely
dry i mean i knew you know harrison ford
was in it
um and i knew steven spielberg the guy
who'd made jaws made it and george lucas
like the guy who made star wars was
involved and stuff
but i've been telling this story a lot
lately because of the press i've been
doing for masters of the universe
uh because it it influenced what we did
with masters of the universe
um i had known my father at that point
for like 10 years i saw the movie when
it came out so i was about 10 years old
and i knew him as dead like he was dead
father figure stoic
just that's dad dad goes to work and he
pays the bills and
you know he wasn't like my buddy that
was my father
when we went to see raiders the lost ark
that was the first time i met
don smith the guy who was my father
because all of that you know
veneer of i'm the adult here and i'm in
charge and
this is the relationship fell away
when we were at raiders of the lost star
because he was beside himself excited
throughout that movie um because he kept
turning to me and talking to me during
the movie something he never did like
not during the movie not just during the
movie but
my man was not a chatty guy like what i
me i get that from my mother definitely
not from my father he was kind of quiet
dude
but that day he was going on he was like
this is exactly like the movie i used to
watch
like when i was a kid and we'd go to the
movie theaters and we'd go on a saturday
and then they'd end it but you didn't
know what happened it's called
cliffhanger and then you had to go back
the next week
to watch this is great he's got i can't
believe they're doing that he was
a different person all together i got to
see the fanboy
like in his heart like you know he
wasn't he didn't wear his heart on his
sleeve like i do and [ __ ] he wouldn't
watch
[ __ ] tv shows and cry like i do and
stuff like that he was a working dude
like you know
loved movies but like they were just
movies
they didn't infuse his his soul or maybe
they didn't he didn't know
like how to express it or anything like
that but in any event
watching watching him like reduced
to being a child again watching raiders
the lost ark
made me appreciate that movie so much
more it instantly became one of my
favorite movies not the
least of which is it's a fantastic film
like
just epic storytelling and especially in
the in the 80s and you're a kid that
[ __ ] movie is right up your alley and
[ __ ] like that but
seeing my dad see raiders the lost ark
had a big effect on me and that's what i
wanted
for masters of the universe revelation
because our job was to make a show
for everyone who grew up watching the
old show we were the
fan service of the three he-man masters
of the universe projects
that mattel was working on and stuff so
you know for me i'm like this is going
to be like that situation with my dad
they're going to be a bunch of people
who are in their 40s and 50s
who are going to be sitting down and
watching this cartoon with their kids
because it meant something to them as a
kid and
like since our thing is so [ __ ] you
know
devoted to what it is to to masters
universe
it does look and play like their [ __ ]
childhood
there a lot of kids are gonna have that
experience that i had
watching raiders the lost ark with my
dad watching masters the universe
revelation
with their parents because of the
experience i had i want that
for other people like that was a
beautiful moment in my relationship
with my old man i always loved my father
but like i fell in love with him that
day where i was like oh my god he's a
real person
he's not just like [ __ ] dad he's he
also had a childhood
he [ __ ] went to movies too and like
he could get geeky about
[ __ ] as well so like i you know
that played a big part in my life and
and and
so much so that we put it liberally
sprinkled it all throughout our series
masters of the universe of revelation so
it
raiders the lost ark insanely
influential um
in fact in our episode two like i put up
a tweet
uh yesterday about like how every one of
our episodes of the first five
homage like a different 80s flick the
second
episode is a very big temple of doom
homage
um so yeah it's it's in my creative dna
but it's also my personal dna
i cannot think about this movie without
thinking about my father i saw every one
of the indiana jones movies with my dad
with the exception of
crystal skull and each time he was like
a [ __ ] child
and not childish like you know [ __ ]
phone popcorn and [ __ ] like that but
just
the joy in his heart you know like
it's like seeing a fan seeing the fanboy
in him and that was rare in those days
like nowadays you know drop a
[ __ ] dime and some adult is willing
to tell you i saw a bunch of [ __ ]
tweets from people after the teaser drop
where they were in tears or talking
about like i'm crying right now i get it
like that's now a part of our culture
thank god back then
i was not a part of our culture so i got
to see a piece of him that i never would
have seen
you know that's one of the reasons i
wound up in entertainment it's a
powerful document for change
and that changed me changed my
relationship with my dad
and so i hope a lot of people have that
with master's universe revelation
i have it every time i go back and
re-watch raiders the lost ark brings my
father
back to life right then beauty of that
movie is it was shot as a period piece
so it doesn't tend to age you know like
you revisit it and it
looks i mean now they got a 4k [ __ ]
version of it so it must look like it
was shot yesterday
but it it just doesn't age it doesn't
feel like oh this is dated look at him
wearing those [ __ ] jeans
asking watch jeans look he's got that
dumbass you know [ __ ] open phone and
[ __ ] like that a razor phone
it's it's [ __ ] timeless so it works
whenever you watch it
yeah no it's it is a it is a masterpiece
on
many many kinds of levels you know when
i first started talking to potential
collaborators about
splinter about the short film they were
always like you know how do you
you know what what style do you think
you want to go for did what does it feel
like how does you know if you had to
sort of mention
you know a filmmaker that you're you're
pettering after it's like well
spielberg like you know spielberg was
the filmmaker of my youth
for for better and occasionally for
worse but mostly for better
but there's there's a there's an ease
and a sort of invisibility to the way he
directs
that it's not obvious he's never calling
attention to the fact that there's a
camera there
but it's always moving it's always kind
of like finding things and new things
and he uses
framing and shadows and and you know i
mean
the first when indy walks into the to
the bar in nepal
you know it's marion small in the frame
she's got the
the shot glass goggles and always sees
the shadow of indiana jones
on the wall behind her just looming over
her larger than life
i think i always knew you'd walk into my
bar someday like just
[ __ ] like that where he's playing with
with form and light and sound and shadow
and all that
um if i can if i could bottle you know a
tenth
of that just sort of innate skill
um it would it would it would go a long
way
so yeah and that movie is just it's
remarkable
even given the fact that you know at any
meeting you have in hollywood today they
will always ask you what are the sticks
right like what are the stakes of your
story what will happen if you're if your
hero
wins or loses what will happen if he
fails what's hanging in the balance
and yeah the stakes for indie ultimately
are very very small they feel like it's
we got to keep hitler from getting his
hands on the greatest weapon the world
has ever known
but in fact it's i'm just going to save
this girl i'm sweet on
which is not insignificant was it la is
it last crusade where he's like
nazis i hate these guys
[Laughter]
you should you should read books instead
of burning them
um yeah man just uh you know
a lot of a lot of culture in the world
pre-exists the united states you know so
a lot of things that we take for granted
and enjoy and
part of the arts for years came from
places that
aren't here raiders of lost ark
that's as american as a guest baby
that's that's
that's our legacy well not mine i had
nothing to do with it but that's the
american legacy in this world it's like
look
look what we did we remade the
cliffhanger
just like they used to back in the day i
mean they laid the groundwork for what
the marvel movies
would become you know all of those
movies that we enjoy today
using the same [ __ ] language created
by steven spielberg and george lucas
years and years ago
same cinema language so uh hats off
pun intended to indiana jones the man in
the hat himself
um happy 40th birthday thank you for one
of the greatest times in my life that i
ever had
with my father um and i'm sure that goes
for a lot of kids i think a lot of kids
had that same experience with their dads
with their moms
but let's be honest probably more their
their dads um
not to say like moms can't enjoy this i
don't want to [ __ ] read an
article online going [ __ ] kevin smith
says
women don't like raiders lost that's not
what i'm saying at all but
my you know i i watched all the energy
jones movies with my dad i saw a few
from with my mom but you know she was
like that's your thing with your father
so yes and happy 40th anniversary
to tom selleck sadly having to make
one of the worst career decisions um
they wouldn't let him off uh magnum is
that it
let him out of magnum he was cast as
indiana jones there's there's pictures
on the internet
of him in the costume mustache bushy as
hell
um yeah hey banff man
can you banff man get in here save us
banff man
bamf find that picture mark's talking
about would you
i will google the tom selleck
uh indiana jones picture yeah that
exists
did he he got that far that they put him
in an outfit
wow um
i'm seeing a lot of photoshop deals
like deep fakes doug
unfunny in chat says test footage is on
the dvd
extras oh
so you might be able on this very box
set that we're talking about that
somebody's going to win tonight
i guess you might be able to see what
tom selleck he was cast he turned it
down says
zesty clam do you want to
mong says i believe it was the test
footage
langley nealy says there's a screen test
of him
tripping through says hundred percent
tom selleck was it was all in the dvd
collections yeah so apparently you can
see it
agent exodus says tom selleck's indiana
jones was erased by the tva
so close that's so good um speaking of
which
we had so much to talk about this week
that i didn't get to show you the
[ __ ] premiums man like we'll get into
it next week
they sent a marvel tta
tva box set we still have this is for
jc the bad batch box set that they sent
bamf in here banff man i'm sure you want
to [ __ ]
ogle do you see you get one
i i don't get anything from disney
they're like you get enough dirty looks
well not when we show that next week
i'll give it to you after we're all done
because i'm sure you'll
you'll you did he just [ __ ] banff
away i was getting done talking
i can still hear you i know but [ __ ]
i'm gonna talk to a blank cityscape
um yes afterwards always here in the
city it's like that
really in the show i'm like jim gordon i
turned around you were [ __ ] gone
i hate it when he does that um
all right yeah i'll give you that box we
when we open it
what's inside cool um all right
jc you're here fam fan so you might as
well
do what you [ __ ] come to do all right
so we got three questions the best
of these questions wins the indiana
jones box set
uh jordan said she would figure out how
to send it
so i think tweet jordan at jordan
monsanto
to aren't we picking i thought it was
like we're gonna pick but whoever wins
should
tweet jordan to send your dm your
address sir
absolutely right kids if you want to get
it fast
you're gonna reach out to at jordan
monsanto on twitter and she'll
hook you up you could also ask her about
the jeff's kiss shirt
oh don't do that not if you want that
box set don't do it yeah
really god i'm gonna get some angry
[ __ ] texts going like did somebody
say something to everyone about the
jeff's kiss shirt
i'm gonna i'm gonna throw you right
under the [ __ ] block don't be me
i work with her every day um all right
jc you get to pick all right
where are we going with our questions uh
this is from
josh h we tell them where they can buy
that box set in case they don't win it
um
i'm assuming that every place that sells
box sets
yeah uh here you're gonna get available
at amazon kids it's at walmart it's at
best buy
it's a target this is a physical thing
uh you know so it's not i don't think
you could buy this like streaming right
well it does include digital copies so
if i
if i had to guess you could probably
also buy these same versions not this
box set not with all the goodies and the
extras
right but perhaps the film itself you
could get on itunes or
when was the last time you bought
raiders of the lost ark kids
you know go buy one it's been a while
people like i got one go buy another one
that's the american way this is the
prettiest version
yes um and you know what
if you don't celebrate his 40th birthday
why will anyone celebrate your 40th
birthday one day
wow that took a turn
[ __ ] one hostile man what about you i
turned it around on the audience
buy a box center fudge of the whale by
yourself in your house
yes sitting there fudgy in it wondering
where your [ __ ] friends are
um all right jc hit us we need to know
what they want to know uh josh h
in honor of the indiana jones box set
what other beloved
film character would you give the young
indiana jones treatment
so kind of a prequel series that spans
childhood up through the adventures
we're familiar with
into old man um it's it's a little
off-brand for our show
but um i was a huge fan of uh not just
the chevy chase movie fletch
but the series of books written by
gregory mcdonald and many years ago
i was attached and involved with a movie
called fletch one
w-o-n which kind of told the origin
story
of the character so i always felt like
you know
like don't get me wrong i love the chevy
chase version but like in the books
like fletch is a young man who just like
like apparently just hotter than hell
and [ __ ] gets to have sex with
everybody
everyone's always trying to [ __ ] him
because he's good-looking and [ __ ]
and um you know there were a lot of
books and a lot of different stories so
it felt like wow you could have a whole
fletch-a-verse or something like that so
i i would i think you could still
do that when i was working on uh
supergirl
years ago i got to work with an actor
named chris wood
um who years later i was like you know
i think you're you're our prince adam
and are he-man
um so chris like is a
beautiful [ __ ] man married to melissa
benoist and whatnot
they got a kid but he's funny and
[ __ ] charming and
he is who i always saw like once i met
him not always like because for years i
wanted to make a fletch movie with jason
lee playing that character
and then we both aged away from it but i
felt like wow i told chris wood i was
like you should have your agent look
into whoever has fletch and you should
try to [ __ ] do that as a tv show i
said you would be
[ __ ] perfect and stuff but now i just
read that greg i think it's greg mattola
doing confess fletch with uh with jon
hamm one of my favorite actors on the
planet
he is a great pick as well like he'll be
a grateful because he's impossibly
[ __ ] good-looking
like the character's supposed to be um
so yeah
i think that that book of all the books
i'm like how interesting i
i personally wouldn't have picked that
book to do
it's a good book but like it tells a
story later in his
of in his uh life so it actually follows
the the book fletch in the series of
books
but if i remember correctly
my flesh history i think in confess
fletch they introduced the character of
flynn
the detective who then gets his own
series of books called flynn flins in
and stuff like that
um if i remember correctly i think
that's where his character was
introduced and confess fletch but i
could be
way wrong but anyway
fletch i would do mark over to you
uh i would the young indiana jones
treatment
meaning you get to follow not just
young character but you know in the
prime character
and then old character telling stories
of his own life that it's in a bookendy
feel
uh conan the barbarian i want to do the
early days of conan as a as a wild
hellion
uh sumerian outcast slash survivor of
the
lone survivor of his his tribe to
thief to smuggler to mercenary
up to king um all of it like
if i can just wrap your arms around the
gigantic story that is conan
and hiborian age let me take you back to
the time of high
adventure but that is not this story
yeah but that is a story for another
time oh that'd be amazing yes
there is a time thief when jewels cease
to sparkle
when gold loses who loses its luster
when the throne room becomes a prison
and all that remains is a father's love
for his daughter
max vaughn side out man like for a guy
who was like a classy actor and worked
with you know [ __ ] in the seventh
seal with birdman and stuff
he was not above doing genre he did
everything he was he was ming the
merciless
he was also king oswego and conan
um he was in what was that he was in a
star wars movie as well star wars
he's in strange brew he's in like beer
hamlet
that's right he's brewmeister smith
i could crush your head not
i won't because i need you
take it to level five level five level
five
um all right that's the one question
down all right there's a good question
good question we'll see if that's good
enough to win the box set
right now it's in the lead it really is
right now you're winning the box set
game's on your stick it's yours to lose
let's find out if you're going to win it
jc
next question i'll i'll just sign that
last one i'll throw out dick tracy
i think would be interesting you know
warren beatty still has that
yeah and won't let it go oh
he still has the rights from what i
understand
maybe did mark tell me that somebody
told me
yeah somebody told me like he's got the
rights and he won't let him go
he's just waiting to make that sequel
better go fast limp dick
you're throwing all sorts of shade
tonight man well done
brought you by blue
all right what's our second question um
from thurlow to hernandez
uh what role would you cast alan rickman
in
in the mcu if he was still around
that smells like a [ __ ] box set
worthy question right there
that's a good what a great question
who would alan rickman play
oh i would make him dr doom
yeah god yes are you kidding me
like doctor doom i know a lot of people
like no man he's got to be young and
phil he's got to be as young as reid and
they went to school together whatevs i'm
then give me young
alan rickman this is a world of fantasy
right so i can do whatever i want
give me give me that die hard error alan
rickman
um but i'll take any error alan rickman
alan rickman one of the greatest actors
who ever lived certainly
one of the greatest actors i ever worked
with in dogma
um but i would yeah oh him as dr doom
just chewing that [ __ ] scenery and
[ __ ] and like
you want to see the brilliance of alan
rickman just go
watch him enter the room in the first
harry potter movie
just his entry like anyone else edges
room they
[ __ ] just enter it he created a scene
out of entering the [ __ ] room all
dramatically [ __ ] closing all those
curtains getting up to the front
and then like being very alan rickman
where he was like take out your books
and turn like him as dr doom
that's my pick what about you uh i think
if if if you could have okay
am i looking for a new character he's
playing or i'm am i just casting him in
the mcu
replacing somebody who had been cast i
think a new character
a new character that makes it harder
because they've done a lot of [ __ ]
characters
but oh you know who they haven't done
yet and everybody was waiting for him on
one division
mysterio no mephisto mephisto i like
mysterio though
mysterio we already had one of them i
already had one um
i think here's here's here's what i
think
we are going to need a new kingpin
because i don't think i if i have to
guess when we get daredevil back
i'm not sure if we're also getting
vincent nonafrio as kingpin
um so i think that could be super fun
i think there is a version of to play by
my initial rules
of young young alan rickman as loki
would have been amazing
um on in chat somebody had a good
suggestion that i was like oh [ __ ]
galactus said closing midnight 4-1-1
ooh nice yeah that's pretty that'd be a
pretty hot take
another good take i saw here was phil
d187
said professor x in a world where we
were
you know recasting yes or magneto
i mean let's be honest he could [ __ ]
play a lot of characters
um that's a good question though any
chance to [ __ ] bring up alan
keep him alive that's a good thing
um sherry king says how have you
maintained
weight during lockdown somehow i've had
a pandemic 30 weight
30 pound weight gain yeah i did you know
i've gained weight as well
i'm still trying to take off [ __ ]
quarantine 15.
um and probably will be trying to take
it off for the rest of the summer and
stuff
but uh yeah i feel that
let me tell you i'm happy the show is
this little box
because if you saw it down there you'd
be like what the [ __ ] what are you
pregnant kev
i've just been i've just been eating my
feelings
about the pandemic i'm glad when we
returned to the bar that there was a bar
between us and the audience
you're not kidding man that [ __ ] bar
hides a lot hopefully
jc ripped the sink out so we can get as
close to the bar as possible
banff man have you made any
refurbishments in the year that the
bar's been closed
uh we could probably take the drink
rails out where the bottles are
and get you a little closer let me get
you another six inches
that'd be good
yes it would put our guts right under
the bar that'd
uh mad matt four two four two and chad
says rickman
as rick jones could you imagine the
oldest rick jones in the [ __ ]
marvel universe hello mr
banner why do you have to detonate
the gamma bomb
now did you ever see rickman in the
january man
yes where he plays like a bohemian
artist one of my
favorite rickman performances is uh
other than of course the ones we all
know
um find a movie he did called closet
land with madeleine stowe
two lander where he plays a guy who's
interrogating
a woman it was a like uh an amnesty
international
influenced movie about prisoners of
conscience and he is
astounding in it another
and that's like a 90s early 90s
performance
and i never see anyone talk about it
closet land it's called i don't even
know if you can readily if it's readily
available anymore another movie like
that that was uh
so [ __ ] like good and i was thinking
about the other day
did you ever see jeff goldblum's movie
mr frost
no oh [ __ ] go
do yourself a favor and go find it is it
i think a european film british film or
something like that
it's got the actress kathy baker in it
as well
um i want to say alan bates maybe i'm
wrong but it's definitely
jeff goldblum and it's jeff goldblum
playing the devil
so it's him in an insane asylum and he
like has a series of conversations
with kathy baker's like character and
who
she's like there's no such thing as the
devil of course like in all of her
conversation with him throughout the
movie and the things that he does and
manifests
she starts questioning whether this guy
really is the devil but
jeff goldblum doing the devil is the
movie don't get nearly enough
mentions or credits but it has like
a horrifying [ __ ] few sequences in it
man
like pretty pretty damn intense stuff
drag it down if you can that sounds like
a like a
like a quintessential 80s kind of high
concept low budget version of genre
which is
what if the devil was in an insane
asylum and has to convince somebody that
he's the actual devil who won't believe
him
oh look i love me devil movies man like
i
love the other morning i woke up i just
started writing a devil movie
no no immediate plans to do it but i'm
like i got to make a devil movie before
i [ __ ] leave this world
because i love them so much like you
know being a raised a catholic kid
that was like you know the devil is like
[ __ ] darth vader the catholic faith
and [ __ ] so like he's always
fascinating bad guy so i you know
rosemary's babies one of my favorite
[ __ ] movies and whatnot i i i got a
i'm i'm building a little like a cult
movie
but you know like i'm very race with the
devil but but not a road movie
like more like parked with the devil
not i guess that's that's that's not a
hot sell but
what if the devil was in the passenger
seat of a car that wasn't driving
and and he had to convince people that
he was the devil so they'd give him a
ride
there you go doesn't they care we'll
call it
that will make care that's good um i um
if
yeah i i'm i started that
and nothing serious where i'm like
that's my next movie but i'm like
you know whenever i'm bored instead of
like [ __ ]
you know surfing youtube or something
like that
i'm gonna just throw a few more pages
into this like
[ __ ] devil movie i'm gonna treat it
like one of them christmas clubs back in
the day
put like a quarter in every [ __ ] week
and then
you know when christmas rolled around
you had like 10 bucks or whatever the
[ __ ]
your parents made you do it that's what
i'm gonna do with my devil cult script
all right man but yes go find mr [ __ ]
mr frost i'm telling you
some [ __ ] dark [ __ ] uh all right
banff man
bamf all right let's let's get to our
third question
last one this is from neon gorilla
if you had to go on your own indiana
jones adventure
what would you be searching for and who
would your sidekick be
and i think we have to say it can't be
jay
and mark but it could be anybody else
who's making up those [ __ ] rules
can't be your existing friends yeah it's
like you got to create a new one
um all right what would i be
what would i be looking for i know me
i'm [ __ ]
well when we were kids when raiders of
lost ark came out
me and ernie o'donnell um who's uh he's
been in a bunch of the movies he made
his rick darris and clerks and
he built smod castle um he's my smart
castle partner
um we would play raiders of lost ark he
would play indiana jones and i would
play bellock
and we uh wrote a script
for what we hoped would be a super eight
movie
called indiana jones and the lost ball
and baal was like some sort of pagan god
like you know that we read about in the
bible because we were catholic school
kids and [ __ ]
and uh i uh you know we dreamed of
making that movie we played the
non-movie version of it
over and over again like in uh in this
clay hill
that ironically is over by like right
around the block from where brian
johnson's parents live where brian
johnson grew up
and um i remember like we would always
recreate the scene
where you know he was up on the cliff
with the [ __ ]
the bazooka and you know
he's like ah you know and he's like
jones
you know tenacity surprises even me
and i remember i was for some reason you
know i always remembered
the line is him being like jones i'll
give you one last chance
jones and ernie would stop the game all
the time to be like
you can't give me one last chance i have
a bazooka
like you have no guns like uh i'm giving
you one last chance we would have logic
battles
um so let's see
oh i got it so this is also ernie
o'donnell
related we were such massive fans
of raiders of the lost ark and whatnot
um
we were in catholic school going our
lady of perpetual help
and uh sister teresa was doing for the
eighth grade play that year
uh they were doing king david so
we were in sixth grade i think me and
ernie at the time
maybe seventh i think it was sixth grade
yeah sixth grade so
uh they needed uh you know an ark of the
covenant
or you know because at one point when
the you know the ark is being brought
into the city david is
dancing in front of it or whatever [ __ ]
and so
me and ernie were like we'll build it
we'll build the ark of the covenant
because we've mowed that movie really
[ __ ] well
uh that was our only like we weren't
builders
model makers or anything like that what
what the reason we thought we could do
the job is because we had seen raiders
of the lost target awful lot
i'll be honest with you man like ernie
is way more talented he's a builder he's
[ __ ] been an architect and for years
and
and building [ __ ] what not so in
construction so like it stands to reason
but he built
a pretty damn [ __ ] convincing art arc
out of like you know foiled [ __ ] art
paper we had two
broomsticks to [ __ ] carry it we took
these two
dolls that i had best of the west dolls
covered them in clay to turn them into
the angels on top and [ __ ]
um so it was in the play and then it was
in just on display i think in like in
the school for like a long time then i
think ernie got to take it home and who
knows what happened to it after that so
long story short my raiders of the lost
ark quest would be
for our 1981
82 uh ark of the covenant that me and
ernie built
for the king david play and [ __ ] because
that would be
an amazing showpiece to have in my house
like what is this and i was like oh
you're kidding me me and ernie built
this when we were like [ __ ] 11 years
old man
and like here it is the lost ark of the
covenant and in that case
i would be literally correct it was
truly the lost ark of the covenant
uh that's very very sweet and i
appreciate the sentiment
it feels like it's a slight dodge of the
question it really is
but it was well told and that's that's
the key you guys
it almost doesn't matter if the story is
well told
masters of the universe revelation
coming soon july 23rd
uh if i have to do an indiana jones
style movie in which i am the hero
i feel like it's um because i do not go
deep in the catholic
uh lore so i i can't pull more artifacts
i feel like i didn't even know what the
holy what the ark of the covenant
was until raised the lost ark like oh
that sounds
metal what is that thing is that real
did they make it for the movie
i knew what the holy grail was because i
had seen monty python and holy grail
which taught me what the grail was um
so i feel like you need something
recognizable to an audience that's also
where like temple of doom kind of falls
apart
for a western audience is that we don't
have a real
knowledge of the shankara stones and
what they mean to um
to people from the you know southeast
southwestern asia
but um i would do indiana jones and the
hammer of the gods
where we are looking for mjolnir and he
whoever
if they be worthy uh will possess the
power of thor
does he get to pick it up does he lift
it in the third act of course he lifts
it in the third act
i'm sorry i'm looking for my money i
could [ __ ] throw it at you
because i want to see and purchase your
motion picture sir
rich and famous contract yes perhaps i
should
where's my phone i must call the mayor
of hollywood
mr mayor yes mark bernard has cracked
the code yet again
not [ __ ] that's dope i'd watch the
[ __ ] out of that man
um and i feel like my sidekick
and the purpose of the sidekick is to
make your life a little bit easier
to have access to things you don't have
knowledge of things you might not get
um you know you need your own salah
ultimately who who greases the wheels in
in egypt for indy to do the things he
needs to do
um and i feel like this person would
grease the wheels of any place she was
for anything you might need so yes my
sidekick is beyonce
because beyonce makes everything
possible
wow nobody
the beehive makes that the number one
opening of all time
alone then you throw in the fans and
stuff
uh look just a little piece of advice
from a guy who's going through it
you might get some people uh some
pushback
people saying that you're baiting and
switching a mark
that perhaps you're woke or something
like that uh
just i mean i'll say beyonce is only in
the second act of this movie she doesn't
go to the very end she doesn't start the
very beginning
she shows up and uh and and like makes
everything better
and then well you know have a lovely
song to walk off into the distance on
i am the monarch of the sea and but it's
beyonce [ __ ] doing something cool
uh let me get so the story line is that
she's a better indiana jones than
indiana jones and so he steps aside and
she wields moleniere
yes because of course beyonce is worthy
of the power of thor
and uh and indy is like you know what it
ought to be you
it's not the years honey some mileage
and you have less mileage
so it should be you um look take this
with a grain of salt but valentine
production said
mark went from a great idea to a
terrible one
was it the beyonce then maybe you lost
him at the beyonce you had him
you had everybody at moulin year but uh
you we went too far
you soared too close to the sun on wings
of wax you know
it's a [ __ ] icarus problem it's
always going to be there
and you know beyonce it uh
she's an acquired taste for some mark uh
mark's got a blind spot when it comes to
beyonce
and you just saw it i mean
kevin i don't know if you know this
about me but i am not ready
for that jelly i'm just not
but no one is i know what he is so
a man's reach should exceed their grasp
or what to heaven for
so true i'm gonna wrap my arms around
that jelly
as mean dave says in in comments mark
wants to put a ring on it
i uh i am i'm ready for that surfboard
um the uh that answers our questions
that's all of our questions it's three
so we have to pick a winner before we do
that
i forgot did you watch sweet tooth yet
i've seen the first two
of sweet tooth and it's great is it i
mean doesn't it make you a shame that
you're like i'm a writer too
you know like if i'm most people i'm
like sure you are
yeah because it's like there are things
you know are going to happen
you know like you know sadly after the
pilot that something is going to happen
that puts sweet tooth on the trail yeah
like he's going to he's going to have to
leave his home and venture out into the
great wide world
yeah um but the the mechanics for that
are interesting you know that once he
meets um
the man who is ultimately probably going
to be his sort of guardian angel
slash guide slash bodyguard
big man the big man um
that there's going to be some tension
and
a desire to pawn the kid off on somebody
but you know that at some point they are
going to be bound together lone wolf and
cub style
for this journey but the mechanisms by
which
you refuse the call are interesting and
tempting
um the world that it's beginning to
build even slowly by the episode two
um are are fascinating like what what
why are these children being hunted you
know what's what's
what's the secret of them and why does
anybody value them more than anybody
else
um and then how does that impact other
characters that you meet
um it's just it's all really really
smart and it's all just
you know it feels like the ted lasso of
apocalyptic dramas
which is there's a bunch of hope it's
really really sweet
um but it's not on a [ __ ] poster the
test lasso
of apocalyptic dramas mark bernardin
it's like that sounds like a code phrase
for something or you would
are you activating a winter soldier of
your own sir i think he's having a
stroke kid
those words don't belong to it you know
what is the test lasso though like what
is a total ted lasso
hacks on hbo max have you watched it yet
not yet it
is it's it's ted lasso same formula
funny as [ __ ] like edgy dirty funny as
[ __ ]
and then an incredibly like
soft gaping heart um
ted ted's a little more gaping hearty
than hacks is but very similar those
shows i loved it hacks is
absolutely [ __ ] wonderful they get
they need to give gene smart
28 emmys this year she's so [ __ ] good
in it yeah i think she's gonna have an
arm full by the time that
that ceremony is done mm-hmm
um something yes i saw somebody go like
they didn't like
they didn't lie i just passed it john
miller said sweet tooth is pretty awful
really like i i gotta be honest with you
i don't think so i
i mean i think it's like the gold
standard if you can make something that
moving that beautiful
like you know but like hey everybody's
mileage may vary
there are some people for whom that is
not their jam
it doesn't mean it's bad like there's
lots of things um
maybe not as many as people think there
are for me which is like i watch it and
recognize that it has quality but it is
also not for me but you know what
just it doesn't fire my receptors it
doesn't you know strum my guitar
but i get it that you might like
bridgeton was that for my wife my wife
loved it i'm like you know what this is
just not for me
not saying it's bad i'm saying that it's
not my jam
they got one of these fast and furious
movies coming out any minute now i ain't
seen
one of them yet and i had all the
pandemic to get to it i still ain't got
through that don't mean i'm like [ __ ]
those movies i just
you know just yes as an i'm not a car
guy so it hasn't really spoken to me yet
but everyone's like come on dude it
ain't about cars i'm like
are you sure it's about family
and also cars hashtag a family
fleet of cars every commercial i see
there's a car in a spaceship there's a
car
jumping out of a building there's a car
of some dude's ass like
they do crazy things for cars but in any
event it's not like i don't watch it
because i'm like campaigning against it
this just
hasn't grabbed me yet because cars
aren't my thing same way that mark was
like ah burgerton
it wasn't really necessarily for me so i
guess you're right maybe there'd be
people who look at sweet tooth and
they're like
[ __ ] this dear boy i thought i think
it's incredibly moving
um no one in chat wrote
i don't have time to watch all these
shows i thought that was an excellent
point because i'm like you know what
i also don't have time to watch all the
the shows that i want to and it's
sometimes it's hard picking out like
what it is
you're going to devote your time to yeah
but sweet tooth for me was like i i
did not regret a second i spent with
that show beautiful
i feel like we're going to be able to
get you back on board or
on board for the first time with fast
and furious once they eventually do
what has been threatened will happen
which is a crossover with jurassic world
and so if there are now dinosaurs
and cars i feel like i can get you
are they are they seriously talking
about crossing those two franchises over
i mean they're
universal's two giantest jewels in the
crown
they're both contemporary and that they
take place in the modern world
there is technically nothing keeping
them
from crossing those two things together
i mean i guess like fred flintstone slid
down a [ __ ] dinosaur's back after
work was done i guess
vin diesel could drive down a [ __ ]
brontosaurus's back
it's like listen guys jump a pterodactyl
we gotta get down back how do we do it
there's only one way
we got to steal a dinosaur
robert mills says uh 80s cartoon
cadillacs and dinosaurs that was a thing
he's right a few people daddy o24 says
but then it's cadillacs and dinosaurs
spiderman cadillacs and dinosaurs as i'm
happy to see that many people remember
cadillacs and dinosaurs
um i remember it fondly if we can get
something even
a fraction of that cool out of fast
11 jurassic drift
then uh then i'm here for it witch hazel
wrote in comments
sense should keep them from crossing
this over but
come on come on there's cents and then
there's money
yeah and there's dollars and cents and
they're like they're gonna meet
dinosaurs kids
um jc i think it's unfair
to make uh me and mark uh pick the box
set winner so banff man bam you
yeah i think you have to be the oh god
i'm gonna get so many angry tweets um
last responsibility is banff man the
first
six tweets are gonna be from liam
neeson's kids and then the last ones are
gonna be from
the two people i don't pick
um
i'll go i'll go with the rickman we'll
go with the rickman
thurlow to hernandez
we got a winner ladies and gentlemen
according to jc
thurlow wins with his question of the
night about alan rickman
he's gonna win the indiana jones four
movie collection from paramount movies
man you reach out to
jordan monsanto thurlow and uh
she will hook you up i'm already getting
yelled at in chat that was a terrible
pick jc
thanks curtis oh god the internet
won't let you down will it right
what what does this thing go for let's
see what it costs at amazon uh
on amazon this bad boy is a 70
box set you saved 21 bucks so
really this is a uh 80
89 90 dollar [ __ ] products that with
the
yeah the list price is 90 99.
[ __ ] wow for watching fat man beyond and
coming up the question that
uh only jc seems to like you have just
won
uh uh 90 value are you really getting uh
[ __ ] just from curtis they like then
everybody else rallies
behind me just pass me a lot of love
everyone's like leave them alone
great pick jc says jeremiah maxwell
jason he says rickman was the correct
choice there you go um ah the internet
where there's always somebody
[ __ ] up somehow even though they have
no proof of that whatsoever
go figure um thank you for playing kids
uh thank you for your questions thanks
jc for for making that uh sophie's
choice so that me and mark didn't have
to be the bad guy
thank you for shouldering the burden uh
we are now
on hour 16 of our telethon kids
this show is literally going on for
three [ __ ] hours
three hours and 21 minutes uh pretty
soon it's going to be monday
this is why they don't give us a tv
version of this because they're like you
realize you'd have to fit into a box
that begins and ends your show just
happens and goes on for a few days and
[ __ ]
our chair was a like a bag of holding
it just it goes all the way down i
wonder if we could ever get to like
like a you know like a telethon show
where it's just like we're in hour 12 of
this [ __ ]
um i 100 believe we could we just need
to pick the charity
and like you know what guys we're going
to just [ __ ] be here
bam on may the 4th
2020 i hosted a 24-hour live stream at
scum and villainy
so i'm sure if i can do it we could do
it together
were you there for strict 24 i was
i was there the whole i mean some of
this stuff was like pre-roll
so it would be like an hour of pre-roll
but even when it was
uh like we were showing a pre-taped
segment i was still on chat
wow man yeah we should do it
yeah can you remember back in the day
when we would do
30-minute episodes
wow like when we were in defy media like
standing there just
all right that's 30 minutes we ought to
get out of here yeah youtube really only
wants us to be here for 30 minutes or
less
it's true at a certain point like i
remember jordan was like
it's more it's better if you
if they spend more time on
the channel she's like because i was
like well subscription she's like
that was back in the day now the
algorithm is about how much time
they'll spend so she's like so go as
long as you want
like what do you what are you reining it
in for just go
they'll watch it if they if they don't
they don't but like
feel free and so at that point suddenly
it was like the gloves are off let's
just [ __ ] do this for hours
and then once we started doing it at
home it got even worse at least in the
bar there's some sense of like go home
like this is over you're gonna [ __ ]
but here at home it's just like
what else is happening yeah like tuesday
night at 11
30. people like i've got to go to work
tomorrow i know
for some people it's monday morning i
already it's monday night
yeah that's true uh kids
have we kept you long enough did you
learn a lot of things remember we talked
about loki remember we talked about
masters universe remember we talked
about
god we talked about something else at
the top of the show too
all that news lots of news and then all
those questions
so much show thick luscious
show never-ending story that was the
original name for our show
it was taken so we went with fat man
beyond yeah tell us all this time
as old as rhyme you are now caught up
you know everything there is to know in
pop culture unless some [ __ ] happened
while we were doing this 12-hour
broadcast
other than that though i think you got
it all man are we doing this next week
or no
we are doing it on june 22nd
is when we return live and in person
at this coming villainy cantana so
that's nine days from now usually you
see us in seven days kids but instead
you're gonna see us in nine days the
next time you see us
we're gonna be behind the bar for the
first time in a long time
behind the bar with a crowd that hasn't
happened in a year and a half
you're damn skippy man uh tickets will
probably go on sale this week so keep an
eye out for that
they'll go very very fast kids very very
fast tickets will also go on sale this
week
for the grand opening of smod castle
which is going to be happening
july 9th 10th 11th 8th 9th 10th that
weekend
that friday saturday and sunday uh but
tickets will go on sale this week
tickets are now on sale for clerk you
can go see the movie in november with me
and malcolm doing a q
a afterwards malcolm directed the movie
movies about me
mark's in the movie as well he's one of
the people they talk to for heaven's
sakes
indeed go to seesmod.com for tickets for
that
uh where can they get your shirt mark
not the shirt you're wearing but your
your shirt my shirt you can go to
embattled clothing emba tt
led clothing.com if you use the code
mark 15
you'll say 15 off your first order
three days left to put money into
splinter kids
uh you go to kickstarter.com you search
splinter short and uh you could be a
part of history
mark made a made uh you know
a [ __ ] big dent in the universe with
his uh
with his uh kickstarter there man he's
rich he's like [ __ ] kirkman rich at
this point
so buying
be a part of that be it be a producer be
part of the
splinter magic kids be a splinter in
splinter
go to community there's still room for
plenty
um and but b there's nothing else that
i'm going to watch
that i previously did not like and will
like the snatter cut
i feel like that's the the icing on the
cake
stanley and chad is going go till
midnight
um no no
no stanley we've done so much
somebody else pointed out prince
gastronome said my kickstarter raised
107k so good on mark these successors
are rare
very very true absolutely but they
happen to nice people good people
there's a guy who's put in a lot of time
making people happy with the show for a
long time and when he turned around he
was like can you help with the thing
people showed up in droves that's how we
roll here on fat man beyond
we appreciate our audience and
apparently our audience appreciates us
so that's very very sweet
um give it up for banff man without whom
you have you wouldn't have had us today
or any of the [ __ ] days during the
pandemic man banff man making it all
possible and [ __ ] like that there he is
waving at you next time we'll be in the
same room with him
we will breathe in the same air that's
cool
um and since we've all been double
[ __ ] poked
we ain't gonna worry about that air no
more we're gonna share that air
confident are you gonna how are you
gonna feel with a room full of tight
room full of people
it's gonna be a little weird do you have
any policy inside the bar during the
show jc
banff um the
we are supposed to ask people at the
door if they've been vaccinated
um and we are to take their word for it
and that's the kind of official decree
from l.a
interesting um i've been there though
when it's been busy it doesn't you warm
up to it
especially after a few bud light
seltzers yeah oh my god i forgot about
those
um yeah it's been a minute man i i did
announce an
outdoor show but i've not done a show
inside so that's gonna be interesting
yeah like 80 people in that bar
that's a lot of people
it's like the old days we used to do it
all the time never once never once
thought
no we used to just like hug people and
i used to lick the bar just to be a [ __ ]
just hell yeah
i think i was in an 80s music video
you were talking in the hood of a car
i was crazy
i was i used to tell my kid that all the
time i was tony contained till you came
around
she's like who is that i'm like what do
you mean she was an ah forget it
just stop pumping muscle cars let me
tell you the tony container this
show right here is the guy sitting
across from me give it up for the guy
who lumps muscle cars himself
mr mark bernard and ladies and gentlemen
thank you sir
that there is fat man beyond for this
week kids i'm kevin smith i am mark
bernard
uh you tune in next week the same
well well not next week but what was it
the 29th
second 22nd tune in the 22nd
same fat time same fat channel
smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
so say we all
you